pop
on
eh bien j attends je ne sais même pas si
monsieur fromentel rentrera dîner à
marotte en pleine forêt vous voulez vous
qu'il le dise je ne sais pas moi j'ai
des amis des voisins
comment s'appelle-t-il ou habiba
monsieur oui bon c'est que j'ai
absolument besoin de voir monsieur
fromentel mademoiselle vous avez devant
vous un contribuable
hors de lui vous êtes contribuables
comme tout le monde on va il ya encore
moins de chances pour que monsieur
fromentel vour soir il est en vacances
jusqu'au 1er septembre
il ne veut pas qu'on qu'elle lui parler
d'affaires a passé lui qui vous ai dit
de me dire ça tienne consignes mais
qu'est ce que je vois là bas et c'est
lui c'est monsieur fromentel ans a par
exemple
cependant que des milliers des millions
de citoyens protestent contre
l'accroissement des impôts monsieur le
directeur des contributions joue au
tennis et avec qui joue t-il là qu'est
ce que c'est que cette femme là c'est sa
fille un homme gaston pelletier
ouais vous la connaissez non mais je
suis un camarade de deux cercles de son
mari c'est lui qui m'a dit allez voir
mon beau père c'est un homme charmant il
sera trop heureux de vous être agréable
et au fait où est-il monsieur gaston
pelletier joue pas au tennis pas non il
est sorti tout de suite après le
déjeuner ça je vous le jure
oui bon telle est la bonne elle est 100
francs vous allez dire à monsieur le
directeur que monsieur menu désirent
absolument il parlait un de menus alfred
menu l'ami de son gendre
vous n'oublierez pas aimé mais je vais
me faire attraper le cieux ben c'est
pour ça qu'il donne 100 francs si je
vous avais envoyé lui dire une bonne
nouvelle j'aurais rien donner du tout
c'est juste un obus son service un
cocktail la copie d'un fragonard des
décors en a dit là bas c'est nous qui
payons tout seul
je rattrape tout de même quelque chose
puisse à 7 en or je suis toujours
demandé si les directeurs des
contributions paient leurs impôts
doivent s'arranger
quel régime voila voila tout de même
bonjour monsieur le directeur
bonjour monsieur alors j'ai même pas
grotte prend deux mois de vacances
excusez moi mais la sphère qui m'amène
est tellement urgente
et puis je suis un ami de gaston valti
je sais je sais oui alors comme il
m'avait promis que votre accueil serait
des plus agréables et bien je n'ai pas
hésité à faire 50 km en pleine chaleur
pour venir jusqu'à vous et moi aussi je
suis en vacances vous voulez peut-être
que je vous remercie
je vais pas jusque là mais je vous
demande de m'accorder dix minutes je
vous écoute
voici mon camp le 28 février dernier le
conformant strictement à la loi
j'ai envoyé ma déclaration de revenus
aux contrôleurs de mon kart se monte à
41 mille francs le contrôleur de la
rejeter parce qu'elle lui semblait
arbitraire et peu conséquente aux signes
extérieurs de ma fortune
il m'a taxé d'office sur cent mille
francs de revenu et j'ai reçu une
feuille qui me réclamait 18 1432 francs
pour 100 mille francs de revenu ça me
parait régulier à mes phares dont ce
compte est ce que cette taxation
monsieur votre droit mais je le sais sur
le conseil de votre gendre
je me suis précipité à votre bureau des
tirs en vacances j'ai vu votre
secrétaire ce que giroud il m'a promis
de réclamer monde aussi aux contrôleurs
pour vous le faire parvenir et que vous
examiniez l'at-il fait mais je ne
pas monsieur je la puise aussi comment
vous appelez-vous menu alfred menu l'ami
de gaston ça ne va pas être mentionnés
sur la couverture
ouais mais ni voilà 17 rue de moore s'en
fait il ya une croix bleue allons donc
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que vous êtes particulièrement
recommandée à la bonne heure lacroix et
ses contrôleurs ne me paraît pas
tellement féroce en passant par exemple
adam quel est le montant de votre loyer
douze mille francs oui sur le papier
comment votre vie doit être de 20 milles
seulement les 8000 fois que vous vous
donnez de la malle à nos propriétaires
de connaissances là non plus je vous
donne ma parole d'honneur parole de
contribuables je sais ce que sable je
vous rappelle que je suis
particulièrement recommandé la croix
bleue ceci j'examine votre cas avec
beaucoup de bienveillance mais que
voulez vous jouer là trois domestiques
pour l'appartement de douze mille francs
alors je les évalue à 20 milles c'est un
minimum mais monsieur le directeur
maintenant vous possédez une finale ça
te plaît ou non une bicoque je les ai
hérité d'un an qu elle ne me coûte rien
et ne me rapporte pas davantage si tu ne
m'aimes un signe apparent de santune
maintenant comment êtes vous venu
jusqu'à un art lot au loto
et qu'est ce que c'est votre voiture
petit dis-je pouvant donc vous avez
envoyées de douz mines une maison dans
le midi je vous ai trois domestiques
nouveau régime
non vous fait donc trois repas par jour
pour un repas copieux pour spécialement
ici monsieur vous avez une superbe vous
êtes fort bien navigué et vous fumez des
havanes
un cadeau way et vous voulez nous faire
croire que vous menez ce train là avec
41 mille francs par an mais c'est à dire
qu'on évalue en vous remis à 100 mille
francs
votre contrôleur a fait preuve d'une
immense 8 exceptionnel mais monsieur le
directeur
j'ai signé ma déclaration sur la foi du
serment mais si ma foi au fait votre
déclaration il s'est mis nos lampes
acier vous appris à je constate d'abord
que je vous ne désirez pas les
assurances sociales preuve que vous ne
payez pas mais ceci n'est pas de
l'ensemble je ferme les yeux vont le
contesterait playmate bienveillance je
vous demande pardon je les paye
ben alors pourquoi ne déduisez veulent
pas j'en avais le droit mais nul n'est
censé ignorer la loi
trop tard nous sommes le 4 août et vous
la vie que jusqu'au 30 juin pour
adresser une déclaration rectificative
en revanche je vois que vous mentionnez
deux enfants à votre charge que l'agent
team 6 et 8 ans voulait ça fait suite
art oui mon excuse c'est que je n'en
suis pas le père d'an sont les enfants
d'un avis à moi
pharmacien à bayeux il en a déjà neuf
alors je m'occupe des deux derniers je
suis très vents monsieur le directeur
et vous les avez adopté non mais sa
lancée le famas et de bayeux qui après
des grèves dans une épave
mais c'est moi qui paye leur éducation
mais l'état n'entre pas dans ses
subtilités
le père légal peut mentionner tous et
sans enfant n'est ce pas qu'il soit
légitime reconnu ou adoptés même si les
cocus et s'ils ne seront pas lui ouvrir
de sam large mais demandez à un
dégrèvement pour 200 enfants qui n'ont
aucun lien de parenté nous vous voulez
rire monsieur voudriez quand ramassés
dans la rue 150 et c'est nous qui
finirait au par vous de voir de l'argent
le jeu vous demande pardon mais le
contrôleur les avait admis mais cela
soit vrai de ce fait il vous avait
rabattu 4200 francs
il est fou on y rajoute on me suis peu
croyable
ça vient me demander une diminution est
majorée pour me demander d'examiner
votre dossier monsieur jeu l'examinent
nous disent au dos 18 1432 francs 32
plus 4200 également 22 1630 232 abbas a
par exemple vous êtes mariés oui vous
avez votre livret de famille reprend sur
moi ce n'est pas prévoir où vous êtes
vous mariée à brighton a break tu
t'attendais en angleterre mais pourquoi
vous êtes-vous mario l'angleterre
ma femme est anglaise c'est le consul de
france qui a procédé au mariage
non c'est un pasteur anglais c'est tout
oui j'ai l'armée survolait vous présente
rien et ma femme à la première occase
votre concubine monsieur aux yeux de la
loi française vous êtes célibataire je
l'ignorais alors et alors tous impôts
sont frappés d'une majoration de 25 soit
5658 x 0,8 mais c'est scandaleux je vous
en prie monsieur comme je vis avec ma
germaine depuis 26 ans je l'épousé se
donne et terriblement des pensions mais
ça ne nous regarde pas nous voilà d'où à
28000 290 francs 40 ans mais j'ai
insisté pour voir sa table a dit mme
loiseau je vois là des frais
professionnels qui me semble important
qu'elle ait de votre profession je suis
vice-président de l'oeuvre des filles
mères c'est tout oui ça m'occupe du
matin ou soit sa voix à porte en rien
absolument rien n'a vraiment pas de
jetons de présence aucun mais alors
monsieur ce n'est pas une profession les
faits c'est une fonction bénévole je
vous en félicite
merci monsieur dior guess alors de
quelle vont nous parlez vous de frais
professionnels comme un tel monsieur moi
je ne sens pas n'a pas de profession pas
de frais professionnels
je ne me parle de ce que j allais
secrétaire ou quel jeu donne mille fois
par mois il s'appelle année si c'est
votre affaire ça vous prie aussi en
donner 3000 dans celles offertes vous
devriez pas figurer sur votre
déclaration d'une même scène aucun
rapport et sur une tendance est
identique ce n'est pas plus une
profession de faire la charité que de
tromper sa femme monsieur ledit rapport
c'est plus louable mais du point de vue
fiscal c'est la même chose
mais alors d'où proviennent vos revenus
de valeurs industrielles alors votre
seul travail consiste dans à détacher
des coûts pour tous les trois mois et a
pleuré sur l'avenir d'ee
mais il m'est impossible d'admettre que
vous ayez besoin d'un secrétaire pour
cela je movano français de réintégrer
douze mille francs principales ceux qui
ont besoin de vos impôts 2006 soit entre
de francs 84 ans plus 25 % comme
célibataire soit 400 mille francs 23
nous voilà 1,30 1331 forum chat par
exemple du noir comme vous êtes l'ami de
mon gendre je vais faire l'impossible
pour vous ramener sa 10 au 30 mille
francs
mais je vais complètement mis les
écuries nikita monsieur je vous prie de
rester courtois
d'ailleurs si vous n'êtes pas satisfait
de mon intervention adressez vous à
monsieur eric directeur général aubin je
vous remercie gilles est aussi
bienveillant vous n'aurez plus qu'à
aller tendre la main sous le porche
d'une effigie on vous dérange pas du
tout j entré je recevais monsieur alpha
de menus que vous connaissez je crois a
parfaitement j'ai vu monsieur au bureau
et je vous ai fait parvenir son dossier
mais recommandé la croix bleue rival à
bonjour monsieur
alors vous avez vous avez causé avec
monsieur directeur veut bien faire et à
bouger
tout à fait je venais me plaindre
d'avoir dix-huit mille francs à payer
par exemple ou à 30 milles alors qu'à
tous les jours où j'ai pris des notes au
crayon pouvoir y envoyer aux voyous très
justement incontestable lumineux à l'evo
tout comme ils se tiennent tous en chose
qui me frappe
ah oui mais je vois que l'an dernier
monsieur venu a payé 9000 francs d'impôt
sur le revenu
il était déjà célibataire sans
profession les deux enfants dont ils
s'occupent n'était pas plus à sa charge
que cette année nous il a donc bénéficié
d'une erreur qu'il importe de rectifier
avez vous demande pardon le contrôleur
avait accepté ma déclaration il a eu
tort monsieur le directeur vient de
constater qu'elle est erronée alors vous
devez la différence entre ce que vous
avez payé
est ce que vous deviez réel
un mais c'est très juste un rappel est
inévitable pour l'année dernière pour
les autres et oui nous avons un droit de
regard sur les cinq ans qui précèdent
l'année en cours mais qu'est ce qu'on va
me réclamer encore moi je sais pas au
juste nous examinerons enfin admettons
que vos revenus tt les mêmes chaque
année vous devez aller et à une centaine
de milles froid quoi à new york
cent vingt mille au maximum vous êtes
des partisans mais je sors et maintenant
je suis ce type reste à faire j'épouse
ma part je rends les enfants aux
pharmaciens
j'envoie tout mais capitaux suisses je
vend des meubles
je vise à l'hôtel et ensuite je vous
défie de me réclamer un sou mais dans
ces conditions mais je n'y songe aux
mêmes trains et fable pour ne pas payer
d'impôts il ne s'agit pas d'être pauvre
il s'agit de savoir s'y prendre bien
bonjour monsieur
non non non
non mais quelle mufle or ces
contribuables moi je vous ai trouvé bien
gentil comme en voilà un homme qui
déclare 40 mille francs de revenus voulu
prouver qu'il en a au moins cent mille
l'off road est évidente
ils devaient les droits quintuple sur la
somme dissimulé soit sur soixante mille
oui mais quand nous rattrapons un peu
d'argent on nous félicite et quand nous
en rattrapant trop nous eng
alors alors qu'est-ce que vous maintenez
encore aujourd'hui il ya un peu plus
d'affaires que d'habitude on est c'est
ce qu'on appelle un 35 ans qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est une circulaire du
ministre qui appelle votre attention sur
les les dernières lois financières
votées par parlement minutier de les
étudier elles seront maudits films map à
la faire pour valeurs dont nous ne
sortons pas un jour la compagnie des
transports sur hoth maintient ses
déclarations elle a bel et bien versé
500 mille francs à gustave pour vannes
le contrôleur ne veut pas arranger ça
c'est vu ni rien à faire il conclut nous
poursuit avec jean c'est impossible
qu'on veuille les sénateurs aussi un
ministre celui de la droite encore ça me
serait bien égal mais un membre aussi
influent du parti radical nous serions
impardonnable établir qu'il a affrontés
qu'est ce que les ministres me
rencontrer je l'entends tissot on ne
peut pas tout chapoval hanoi
il vaut mieux déplacer le contrôleur je
le ferai passer dans un autre
arrondissement
comment s'appelle-t-il déjà et bressols
ah oui c'est petit c'est qu'avec alors
you est belle une façon de soigner son
avancement celui là
quel imbécile madame templiers qu'est ce
que c'est que sa vie c'est la tenancière
d'une maison une tolérance de la rue
saint-augustin
mais elle déclare 400 millions de
bénéfices et sa comptabilité porte deux
cent mille francs de salaires versés au
personnel bas ce qui semblerait indiquer
que les les pensionnaires de sa maison
tout ce 33 % du prix versés par le
client et vous croyez que ces dames ne
touchent pas ça j'en suis certain eh ben
la fraude sera difficile à prouver
ah non pardon pardon mais ce directeur
dès que le contrôleur masse ou 1000 cas
je me suis rendu et moi même rue
saint-augustin
plus j'y suis allée saint jour de suite
chaque fois j'ai pris une femme
différente de les questionner et bien là
les pensionnaires de madame templiers
touche 20%
même la sénégalaise non celle là à 30 en
tout cas il est éclatant que nous sans
droit fait 80 milles je vous félicite
gilles à vous avez fait preuve d'un beau
jeune et d'un solide tempérament ça je
vous félicite au nom de monsieur le
ministre des finances on est aussi
ancien que font les parents vers les
fixes maintenant dites moi avant de
partir j'aimerais que vous me préparer
un rapport favorable sur la sphère
loiseau vous vous rappelez parfaitement
monsieur directeur le diamantaire ccao
20 lignes mais mon tailleur s'intéresse
à lui et comme voilà dix ans qu'il ma
vie pour rien je t'aime folie mal d'être
agréable ça va chaudement madame je vous
remercie mais vous êtes là tout de même
j'aime sawan homme qui travaille moi
aussi vu dans mon petit matin j'ai
besoin d'argent
tu vas me prêter je t'ai déjà expliqué
mon enfant que les sommes qui me sont
versés par les contribuables
vaud dans les poches de l'état pas dans
les miens et l'état de ne pas petit
quelque chose surtout l'argent tu viens
gagner le sou du franc vous l'entendez
géo et madame valtier vous taquine oui
mais ce qu'elle vit pourrir beaucoup de
gens le pensent sérieusement
voilà ce qui m'afflige bref pour moi de
mon vivant non mais tu es ma fille
unique tu est sur d'avoir quelque chose
après ma maman merci papa je vais dire
ça mais créant si ça valait qu'annick du
créancier doit emprunter de l'argent
non non mais j'ai beaucoup de factures
en retard figure toi pourquoi m'en parle
du comme ça parce que pas obtus recevez
monsieur menu moi aussi j'ai eu une
visite désagréable la maison pour line
et albert camus me relancer jusqu'ici je
me retire maintenant maintenant giroud
rester vous êtes un peu de la famille ça
me gêne pas de dire devant vous que je
suis tout à fait embêter
oui ben tu vas me le dire devant ton
mari sam avant serait bien
il a fini d'être richmond marie jo je
sais que les comme tout le monde
ses revenus ont un peu diminué quand je
l'épousé il ya trois ans il avait 150
mille francs de rente
aujourd'hui c'est à peine si lyon reste
entière qu'est ce que vous dites de sa
mort
la crise mais j'appuie sur laquelle
travailler mon genre
gaston est un être délicieux mais ne
sait rien faire quand on est venu au
monde avec de la fortune ou étude en ce
moment à fontainebleau pour voir passer
les cyclistes qui termine le tour de
france
il voudrait tellement que speicher
conserve le maillot jaune
j'avais entendu voilà un garçon de 35
ans qui est en train de perdre toute sa
fortune et qui n'a qu'un souci les
exploits d'un monsieur qui monte à
bicyclette et qui avait plus que je te
dise le jour où giroud ma demande et à
main j'ai eu le temps de mettre en
colère mais je dirais que je sais tout
les perdrix agit comme moi il ya de cela
quatre ans l'espace vous débutiez de
l'administration vous gagner 1500 francs
par mois où toni qu'aujourd'hui tout
gagné 39 mille francs 49500 hilarant du
conteneur et l'avons sera vite puis du
point de vue physique il s'est arrangé
et moi je prétends que d'ici trois ans
ce sera un des meilleurs pratiquement
jambes il sera bien temps
vous regrettez vous m'aimez encore
écouter madame subirait ne vous mettez
tous les dans une situation je peux vous
répondre
le 37 eur 5 j'ai encore ce petit rapport
à rédiger je peux m'installer par là
comme d'habitude chez nous merci
monsieur giroud madame sans rancune ou
moins au matin et puis je tiens à vous
le dire il y a quatre ans moi je me suis
pas mis en colère je dirais même que
vous ne me déplaisait pas du tout un
coup juliette s le tranquille que j'aime
ce garçon dit que j'ai route pendant
vous écrivez à côté moi je vais signer
sa part fait
barry et je suis bien content c'est plus
cher est toujours en tête toutes mes
félicitations
bonjour ma chérie tu vas bien bonjour
mon père bonjour comment ça va très bien
su watier avec vous je ne vous demande
pas trop nous venons d une mine superbe
mais bon si je le crois aussi bien porté
sinon rien
si nous y ce que la campagne réussie
mais alors tant mieux et alors si on
vous allez travailler par la toujours
toujours rien ça la js aussi pour votre
information avant elle à vous ne
repartez pas à bari tout de suite dedans
à 7h05 bon eh bien je vous accompagnerai
à la gare avec ma voiture un an pendant
un petit porto tous les deux au buffet
avec plaisir à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure giro auj les sympathiques moi
j'allais beaucoup cette preview alors
des enfants bonne journée vous avez joué
au tennis
oui seulement avec papa c'est pas très
amusant il joue si miley m'excuseras
mais les enfants mais je lis pas
beaucoup le temps de me perfectionner
moi oui un bon père on va quand il faut
changer mes vacances et me regarder
voler une heure que je règle des
affaires avec giroud et avant lui
j'avais déjà une discussion et puissante
avec un contribuable qui m'a lancé
jusqu'ici ça mais c'est vrai des dons au
fait vous n'êtes pas très gentil pour
comme douce
écoutez il ya dix minutes à peine à deux
kilomètres d'ici moi je revenais
tranquillement de fontainebleau tout
d'un coup je vois s'avançant vers moi
petite voiture qui roulait positivement
d'un trottoir à l'autre
le conducteur faisait des grands gestes
ils achètent tout le temps le volant moi
je me suis dit encore un ivrogne
alors je klaxonne tant que je peux je
les évite à grand peine
en passant je ne pouvais pas faire
attention abc il me répond comme fou de
la vie je veux me tuer je veut écraser
tout le monde
eh bien c'était menu nancy alors je
m'arrête
lui aussi est alors qu'est-ce que j'ai
pris au bon père je vous félicite vous
avez une façon d'accueillir les gens que
je vous recommande chaudement
recommander des fraudeurs ce n'est pas
ma faute
num l'homme le plus honnête de la
theurre jeu c'est voler les tâches les
volets personnes heureusement l'état des
sommes comme moi pour le défendre
arbitrairement comment free parce que
menu m'a rapporté sa conversation avec
vous en vous lui portez ses impôts de
l'année à 30 mille francs
non ça je ne discute pas c'est méchant
mais c'est peut-être régulier mais vous
le menacer d'un rappel sur les cinq
dernières années et ben ouais pas le
droit comment je n'ai pas le droit mais
non monsieur
depuis la loi herriot votre droit de
regard ne dépense pas trois ans qu'est
ce que vous savez ça et vous met il à
résoudre atteint la semaine dernière un
soir en dit non tu étais indigné contre
cette loi et tu as dit c'est au moment
où la france a le plus besoin d'argent
qu'on lui enlève les moyens d'en faire
entrer alors des dents inutile de vous
dire que je les renseigner et menus quoi
quand il a su qu'en plus vous
outrepassez vos droits au j'ai cru qu'il
allait piquer une crise de nerfs pour
moi c'est un homme qui culbute roi dans
le fossé avant d'arriver à paris
mais alors s'il y arrive j'ai
l'impression que vous allez entendre
parler de lui bon là ça me fait de quoi
vous mêlez vous voilà que vous vous
dresser contre l'homme qui vous a donné
ça fait comme même pas du tout je
rectifie une erreur vous réclamer des
sommes indûment mais lui je maquille
d'une tâche il use le mur que je veux on
servir mon pays d'abord et plus
équitable après judiciaires nient tout
de suite que votre menu ne connais rien
à la loi mon devoir est d'en profiter
prends bad et d'un abat mais c'est une
honte enfin vous spéculer sur
l'ignorance des contribuables mais
comment voulez vous que nous en sortions
autrement la fortune de la france
s'élève à 500 milliards
il devrait donc rentrer chaque année
environ 40 milliards d'impôt sur le
revenu mais il en rentre la moitié par
conséquent lehman à nouveau lé 20
milliards par an alors voulez-vous que
nous les retrouvions sinon dans les
poches des imbéciles mm
et ben voilà une théorie péremptoire
ceux qui ignorent la loi p pour ceux qui
la connaissent trop bien
au bas des taux je ne voudrais rien vous
dire de désagréable mon père mais
franchement je n'aimerais pas exercer ce
métier là voyez vous c'est à dire mon
jean que vous centrez ses organes en
chantant juliette on arrive au travail
et je maintiens ma compris pas par donc
quelquefois je caresse des idées folles
qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ces allusions qu'est ce que ça signifie
ça signifie mon cher gaston que je vous
trouve mal qualifiés pour juger un homme
qui depuis 35 ans sert loyalement son
pays en voyant bonfim et puisque vous
n'aimez pas les allusions je vous
déclare en face que vous feriez mieux de
gagner votre vie que du crédit qu'est
celle des autres d'abord cela me
permettrait d'imposer vos salaires et
ensuite vous pourriez faire face aux
besoins de votre ménage
mais quel besoin qu'elle ménage monsieur
je comprends rien du tout contre les
plans que votre femme a besoin d'argent
et que c'est votre oisifs ticket
l'enfance à s'adresser à son père tu as
besoin d'argent
oui à rennes n'ont pas tous types
rentrée la data et nous expliquons nous
voit la semaine dernière tu m'as demandé
dix mille fois est ce que je te les a
refusées dix mille francs pour calmer la
mieux que de ses créanciers la meuf tout
à l'heure il avait plein jardin non etc
ou papa je t'en prie il exagère et moi
je prétends qu'il faut qu'il sache est
ce que oui ou non la maison folie niel
perte est venu tout à l'heure tu as
produire de ces réclamations
c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai c'est les
les fournisseurs s'énerver en basset
d'hommes se calmeront a d'abord cette
année personne open actifs d'idg mais
seulement moi si je ne donne pas
l'acompte sérieux ne voudront plus
habiles débat d'hier ailleurs mais où ça
je dois partout non mais c'est très
ennuyeux ce que tu m'apprends le trait
mais pourquoi c'est d'être comme ça tout
d'un coup et c'est pas tout d'un coup
elle se sont accumulés mais comment ça
se fait parce que tu ne me donnes plus
assez d'argent pour payer ce qui m'est
nécessaire où il me reste à définir ce
kit est nécessaire
on tu sais je fais pas tu relis mais si
tu m'aimes mais au lieu de me demander
de réduire mon train qui ferait
peut-être mieux de gagner de l'argent
que je travaille un c'est ton père qui
te montre la tête un femme à qui tous
les postes vers la bouche depuis cinq
minutes
mais à part bleus elle répète ce que
vous lui seriner faisait plus besoin
d'intervenir au moment tu sais j'ai pas
besoin de papa pour penser qu'à 35
empreintes l'homme qu'il fait rien et
dont les revenus baissent pourrait
peut-être quelque chose pour les
augmenter alors tu voudrais que je
devienne fonctionnaires comme ton père
que je passe ma vie à dépouiller n'est
semblable
eh bien j'aimerais mieux mourir de faim
pas moi et puis ont d'abord ne
s'improvise pas fonctionnaire il faut
être pris tout petit on y avoir la
vocation
alors qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse
je donne des cours de tennis te fatigue
pas seulement moi je look une raison de
le promener tout nu pendant que mon mari
sont les pouces
oui mais mais mais alors alors je
m'arrangerais qu'est ce que tu entends
par là mais où vas tu je vais passer une
re pour le dîner et t'inquiète pas celle
là elle est payée
bon moi qui étais si quoi on t'en moques
était si bonne humeur ce pêcheur cac 40
est ok ce que c'est agaçant c'est un mec
mais qu'est-ce que vous m'agacer
toussaint enfin que je m'arrangerais
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que vous allez être cocus mais
c'est une unique table il a des dettes
et vous ne pouvez pas les payer comment
voulez vous qu'elles en sortent
à moins que vous préfériez être saisi
par ben oui par exemple ce
désintéressement vous honore seulement
voilà j'ai peur que juliette ne vous
demande pas votre avis vous la croyez
capable mais je crois les femmes
capables de tout quand on ne donne pas
ce dont elle a envie mais que voulez
vous c'est ma fille unique
alors j'ai plus l'habitude et à un
certain luxe vous aussi lorsque l'on me
dire non c'est comme ça 28 me dédiais
n'est pas très courageuse là vous non
plus se porte pas aussi vous vous dites
ça pour me faire peur
1 je sais bien que juliette est un peu
étourdi un petit peu futile elle a pas
bon caractère mais ça je peux pas lui en
vouloir
elle tient de vous quoi mais mes de
l'amener vers les bébés filles
d'ailleurs avec qui oh oh si vous savez
pour formuler une allusion aussi direct
il faut que vous soupçonniez quelqu'un
et vous ne soupçonnez personne un homme
riche qui soit susceptible de plaire à
julien de sa voix même là je ne vois pas
naturellement assez marie tous les mêmes
alors vous n'avez jamais remarqué que la
chapelaude et tout le temps fort hills
ce vieillard trois ans de plus que moi
mais pardon non comme directeur d
comme directeur des contributions vous
êtes encore prévert mais comme séducteur
permettez moi de vous dire que vous
seriez impossible
je l'aï d'abord la chapelaude est bien
plus élégant plus agréable que moi il a
cette adoration des femmes qui conserve
les hommes de notre âge et puis rassurez
vous ce n'est certainement pas par
ailleurs que j ai deux s'intéressent à
lui
oui c'est peut-être moins vexant pour
moi mais ça n'est guère flatteur pour
elle elle le combi ne riais les lâches à
petit elle se débat dans des envies ne
vous le dirais pas elle rencontre un
homme puissamment riche pas déplaisant
et qui lui fait l'info mettez-vous à sa
place
elle le regarde quand même qu'ils se
noient s'accroche à ce niveau non la
chapelaude mais quand j'y réfléchis
c'est pas si bête ce que vous dites là
je ne dis jamais rien fait
oui mais deux il ya trois semaines ne
connaissais pas cet homme là est
aujourd'hui sous un prétexte ou sous un
autre et tout le temps fourré ici donc
je te nom de dieu mélicie risques ça sur
la chapelaude revendiquent-ils une
vingtaine de millions aux bombes à la
crise ne tourne pas trop lui en plein de
périodes de sécheresse
la scène reste navigables dans la
comparaison et grâce à la base je
félicite de l'éducation vous avez donné
à votre fille un bravo mais le seul qui
mérite ni reproche ici c'est vous moi la
bourgogne à 20,6 quoi c'est dû l'être a
ravagé vous inquiète tous les obstacles
qu'est ce que c'est monsieur de la
chapelaude non voyons oui c'est vrai ce
serait pas très adroit au contraire à
leur fête fête fête le fait de l'entrée
ce cher la chapelaude
chers amis comment vous portez votre
[Applaudissements]
porte tout à fait bien merci justement
nous parlions neuf ans que que c'était
ma wii et même nous nous attendions à
vous voir les pages avec une bêche
alors moi je vais vous expliquer madame
28 et n'est pas là elle est montée se
changer elle va descendre elle a bien
reçu les si rosie american je fais bien
de fontainebleau vu j'ai vu livrer sa
smet
moi aussi mais je ne savais pas que
c'était un cadeau que vous faisiez un
match aux arcades ou bagatelle mais nous
promenions avant-hier dans votre jardin
tout à coup je me dis voilà une jolie
pelouse et elle me répond je la trouve
un peu nous il faudrait l'égayer avec
quelques rossier américain pouvait faire
autrement que de liens d'adressé
aussitôt une demi-douzaine est
évidemment je suis d'autant plus
sensible à votre amabilité gerra
n'oublie que le jardin est à moi alors
cette lebel c'est pour planter les rosie
oui madame votre fille et moi nous
allons choisir les emplacements et je
ferai des trous mois mais est pas
raisonnable vous fatiguez comme ça à des
exercices physiques ne sont regardés par
la faculté
alors non mais non il faut dire que je
suis président du conseil
d'administration de 23 sociétés
différentes alors je suis un peu sur mon
sujet je commençais je commence à les
confondre les unes avec les autres
alors mon médecin m'a dit installez-vous
pendant trois mois à la craint pas que
fait du jardinage
quand on travaille la terre on ne pense
à rien il devient urgent que vous ne
pensiez à rien et ce régime vous réussit
à la demi-heure le banc
je pense que madame 20 août il va
bientôt descendre
je pense aussi
et hop mais il ya longtemps que de
monter changer de robe quelques minutes
alors jeu on l'a peut-être pas prévu que
je suis si elle doit s'en douter vous
êtes pressé dessus votre régime est bien
descendante et l'aider au jardin nous
commençons sont juliette et quand elle
sera pas de gaston maulin on verra a dit
que si vous voyez giroud début qu'il
peut remporter tout ça j'ai signé mais
un mois j'ai eu une autre idée pour
votre jardin c'est de créer une pergola
le long de la grille parallèlement à la
route je vous apparaît pendant
continuera un avons à nous nous nous
dînons ensemble mais oui madame valtier
m'a invité à l'embarquement départ et
ben alors à tout ado madame brad ou 6ème
tel le rêve free pourquoi parce que vous
avez un mur en plein soleil
j'y verrais très bien de la vigne en
espagne et moi j'y verrais plutôt des
poires
les poires
au nom de dieu de nom de dieu 2 à 1 j'ai
fini mon rapport je suis vraiment elle
n'est pas là non il est d'un jardin est
un pays s'il sait la chapelaude un bon
bah ne le dérange pas je vais laisser ça
sur son bureau à qu'il a signé oui me
charge de vous dire que vous pouviez
remporté tous imparfaits parfait parfait
au 6h30 mission que je pense ce nom mais
non vous avez le temps puisque je vous
conduis accepte suivent altier vous êtes
gentils venez asseyez vous et on va voir
le porto il sera peut-être moins mauvais
qu à la gamme avec plaisir des dangers
au lavo poser une question je vous
écoute vous qui voyez passer tant de
déclarations de revenus
quels sont les professions qui ne sont
pas trop touché par la crise les croque
morts
oui mais il doit en exister d'autres
oui avant oui oui attendait les les
usuriers les marchands de bijoux faut
les restaurateurs bon marché les avocats
qui sont en même temps député et les
syndics de faillite
on peut même dire que cela
s'enrichissent tenez en cognant dans les
revenus ont décuplé depuis trois ans
bah ouais mais tout ce métier là ne
rentre guerre dans mes aptitudes à vous
voulez faire plaisir à votre beau-père
il vous a dit aussi que je devrai
travailler il le dit à tout le monde
c'est une idée oui et bien depuis dix
minutes
je ne le trouve pas si bête son idée est
bien fait bien moins non plus dans la
débâcle actuelle il n'y a que ceux qui
gagnent leur vie quand une chance de
s'en tirer et d'évincer les planteurs de
rosiers voilà n'ont rien une idée ce
mardi d'organiser sa vie c'est bien
c'est facile à dire sa mère sans quoi
quelle carrière choisir vous-même n'en
avais citer que trois ou quatre qui
rapportera mais il ya tout de même
d'autres on peut se défendre des données
l'alimentation on perd pas trop vous
mais j'aimerai pas être efficient de
votre choix je cherche vais je crois que
j'ai une idée dit aujourd'hui où tout le
monde cherche à se restreindre
que penseriez vous d'un homme qui
offrira au public les moyens de faire
des économies sans réduire ses dépenses
vous l'avez trouvée et bien peut-être
tout à l'heure mon beau père disait que
les imbéciles paie parfois trop d'impôts
parce qu'il ya des malins qui n'en
payent pas assez et bien moi je leur
offre mais services aux imbéciles et je
leur dis ceci imbécile vous avez payé
100 mille francs d'impôts l'année
derrière parce que votre déclaration
était mal fait confié là moi je la
rectifie vous ne paierez plus que
cinquante mille et vous me donnez 10 %
sur l'économie ainsi réalisée qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ça que ça existe des
gens qui font ce métier là ça s'appelle
des agents d'affaires
seulement ils ne prennent pas 10 % et
près de 20% alors comment se fait-il
qu'il existe encore des contribuables
comme menu qui s'incline docilement
devant les exigences de l'état lorsque
les agents d'affaires ne font pas assez
de publicité
nous sortons petit comptable sans
conditions sans envergure et moi j'en
connais un lubineau à son bureau rue
duel d'air le très fort l'une très
gentil clientèle avec quatre sous drake
la ville pourrait agrandir quintuplé ses
bénéfices non ils n'osent pas il a mis
un peu d'argent de côté pour faire
sortir et vendre son cabinet dans des
teneurs dit nordine temps qu'est-ce
qu'il en demande ne sait pas au juste
dans les 80 mille ha bon et pour la
publicité de départ puisqu'il faudrait
votre avis pour commencer sans billet à
eau la vie c'est un peu gros allons
allons allons monsieur watier vous ne
vous ne penseriez pas sérieux mais aussi
très sérieusement au contraire enfin
enfin une carrière qui m'attire embêter
l'état et surtout mon beau père alors ça
ça me ferait plaisir mais vous avez
raison il faut lancer ça comme une bombe
et puis il faut lui trouver une raison
sociale un titre cabinet lubineau gaston
vaultier successeur non il faut quelque
chose de plus alléchant de plus
représentatives de la vigilance et au
nom d'une compagnie d'assurances n'en
attendez attendez le la bouée au nom la
boue est obscur et comprendre le parti
un jouet ou un article de ménage non
attendez attendez attendez le led led
haut le ce voyage et trouve l'école des
contribuables c'est pas mal et puis
c'est vrai parce que c'est une école
j'ouvre un coup en quelque sorte japon
français la grammaire fiscale je leur
signale toutes les embûches que
l'administration dresse chaque jour sous
leurs pas comme quoi la loi du 25
janvier 1932 détruit celle du 15 avril
1929 qui reprend sa force grâce au
décret de mai 1933 et en quittant il
faut être très calé pour ça mais je le
serai vous savez moi quand un sujet me
passionne et puis vous serez là giroud
vous m'aiderez pour m'apprendre et vous
vous levez pas réfléchi mais je suis de
l'autre côté de la barricade comme et en
chant mais bon dieu qu'est ce que vous
gagnez par mois trente neuf mille cinq
cents je vous en 9 81 baoulé prenez-vous
par mes bénéfices non aléatoire certains
ou 4 pas trop fatigué
quatre-vingt mille francs dans votre
idée n'est pas neuve mais on peut la
rénover puis c'est internet comme toutes
les affaires elle dépend uniquement des
hommes qu'il a lens on voit là alors
évidemment reste la mise de départ ça
180 mille francs c'est un peu gros pour
moi je pourrais réaliser remarqué mais
ce serait juste des pays
ce serait bête c'est oui c'est ça quand
on lance une affaire il vaut toujours
mieux risqué l'argent des autres
mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire
giroux il évite à la gare parce qu'il
est cet euro il s'est levé on parlera
tout ça en voiture vous n'oubliez rien
non je ne crois pas non
allez-y pas cette mer suite au non je
n'ai plus le temps
on veut que je travaille
eh ben je vais travailler
[Applaudissements]
allô oui mesdemoiselles à de paris bon
j'attends
oui oui c'est moi à vous jouerez super
chat oui oui je suis seul pouvait parler
alors j'avais besoin de cette somme là
pour lequel on plus tard mais oui mais
puisque j'accepte les 14 % + 1 % par
mois commission oui quoi par des 40e si
je pouvais vous en donner je
n'accepterai pas ces conditions là oh
oui insisté encore monsieur p recherche
tutelle m'ennuyer en ce moment
oui bon vous me rappellerai demain sans
faute où il est avéré que genius un bon
parfait merci davance à voir mais ces
personnes tout s'arrange mal la chapelle
bonjour je suis contente de vous voir ce
genre dit ça comme vous voilà
cérémonieux vous avez mis des gants pour
venir dîner à l'eau n'ont cessé pour
bêcher je suis un lieu tout à l'heure on
m'a dit que vous changiez de rome mais
vous avez eu raison
je n'ai pas vu l'autre mais celle ci
elle est sûrement mieux kazan et vous la
robe que vous portez toujours la plus
jolie à l'achat que vous auriez dû
naître au xviiie siècle
merci bon je me trouve à ses jeux comme
ça ne vous plaignez pas il n'y a que les
hommes de votre génération qui savent
parler aux femmes ceux qui les ont
toujours aimé et vous êtes de ceux
largement rentrer à nice au plus
maintenant je m'associe ya quinze jours
encore je les aimais tout
à présent je n'en ai plus qu voulez-vous
être raisonnable on pourrait entrer une
chaussée parce que je voulais dire
que vous êtes méchante je n'ai pas la
tête à écouter vous déclaration à winson
mois d'août bien est ce que ça veut dire
vous êtes très occupé
vous avez des ennuis non pas du tout
ouais ouais ouais on se confie à un
monsieur perche en est pas à son vieil
ami la chapelaude vous écouter au point
en championnat volontairement loge
arrivait du jardin vous parler au
téléphone que vous téléphone mis à part
nous parlait très fort j'ai entendu
c'est pas ma fosse est gay mais ce très
heureux commence à baden 14 % + 1 % par
mois non mais vous vous figurer que je
vais vous laisser dans les pattes d'un
pari gredins g et quand on est gêné on
est bien obligés d'avoir recours à ces
gens là il vaut mieux s'adresser à ses
ennemis vous est implacable aujourd'hui
pardonnez moi mon bon ami mais je suis
tellement énervée s'écouter l'épaule et
finalisons pauligne albespy gaston qui
n'a pas été tellement tellement et
marque
oui on a titillé de quoi je ne veux pas
vous voir préoccupé comme ça pour des
bêtises pareilles tellement secondaire
de questions d'argent vous trouvez opus
comprend si bien ce qui se passe
les fournisseurs vous connaissent depuis
toujours ils vous poussent à la dépense
ils ont quand j'avais leur note est un
beau matin on se réveille avec une
centaine de milford dette
disons 150 pas plus que ça bon eh bien
moi je vais vous signer un chèque tout
sec
ah non alors là chapeau tête impossible
je ne voudrais pas vous de voir deux
cents amis beaucoup
ah bon ça fait 2 120 mais le franc oui
vous voyez c'est impossible comment vous
les mangez au courant d'une somme
pareille vous me la rembourser au
centuple course à part votre présence
par un peu plus d'amitié de sollicitude
on est tellement besoin
vous ne saurez jamais combien je me sens
seul depuis que je vous aime la chasse
nous nous connaissons depuis trois
semaines vous ne pouvez pas m'aimer
encore tant que cela laissez-moi vous
rendre ce petit service je vous jure que
c'est moi qui serai votre obligé si ce
débat je voudrais je voudrais que tu
aimes je restais une honnête femme alors
je je fais le chèque au porteur pour ne
pas vous comprendre mais je prendrai
part de mon souhait ne le prenez pas
voici votre petit sac je le glisse de
temps vous n'avez pas dit un mot pour le
demandez pas fait un geste pour le
recevoir
ce soir vous ouvrirez votre petit sac
vous réfléchirez et puis si vous trouvez
que j'ai été trop indiscrets ben moi
odieux la chapelaude le chèque vous
jetterez tout un panier vous avez
l'expérience
et ben et ses rosiers
c'est là qu'ont les plans donc les trous
sont fait maintenant on se repose
je dérange on reproche surtout mais ce
n'est pas positif pour dire quelque
chose
ton père
n'est pas là non pas du tout non mais
comme ça va être l'heure du dîner
paula la route il faut absolument que
j'aille réparer le désordre de match où
elle est et ce que j'ai dix minutes le
temps d'aller jusque chez moi il revenir
mais ne vous donnez pas cette peine pour
que vous êtes ravissant comme sa propre
aimable malheureusement malgré mes gants
il m'est impossible de me mettre à table
sans me laver les mains au savon bas
vous savez où est la toile f1 à gauche
dans le vestibule
ah bah oui ah bah oui mais ça je sais
pas ce que je sais pas ce que je le sais
adriano merci à tout à l'heure
giroux n'a pas raté son train non ok est
ce qu'il faisait avec ton sac à la main
6 à la chapelaude j'ai rien à moi j'ai
remarqué il voulait se mettre du rouge à
lèvres il jouait peut-être avec machine
mais qu'est ce qui te prends tu vas tout
même pas fouillé dans mon sac
c'est après tout
deux cent vingt mille francs je t'en
prie 1 il est donc mon sac est signé de
la chappe lola je te jure que ça suffit
à tuer ça mettra non par exemple alors
c'est pour demain mais enfin gaston
regard de l'ue et regarde moi mais alors
tu essaies de malhonnête femmes bas
comme en attaque et ratu et je ne sais
pas tout bousculent
cet argent est dans mon sac depuis deux
minutes à peine j'ai pas le temps
matériel de me demander comment je la
rembourse a accepté une somme pareille
d'un homme faute avec lui dans des
termes et je lui ai rien demandé
il a surpris un coup de téléphone que
j'ai eu avec perche hier qu'est ce que
c'est que ce en version à l'usure y es
tu en es là oui ça la révolte et me
voilà prête et de canal alors très
généreusement il accomplit un chèque et
l'a glissée dans mon sac veut vieux
renard et sait s'y prendre pour que les
femmes tombent dans ses rangs il est
vrai qu'il peut pour agir autrement les
coûts de gaston je ne veux pas que des
idées pareilles que je t'aime je suis
incapable de me laisser effleuré par un
autre homme que toi seulement tu
comprends je suis très embêté alors
alors alors là chapeau 2 a profité d'une
minute d'affolement oui maintenant je te
crois et aussi c'est à yichang de
nombreux recueils salon il dit chez moi
me serre la main ils se lavent dans la
cuvette
et et que j'ai le dos tourné veut surfer
ma femme je lui flanquer la figure bras
son chèque
deux cent vingt mille francs attends
attends attends attends qu est ce que tu
vas faire tu me jure que je n'ai pas ça
mettra ses enfants ses comptes
bon ça vient ça vient savez je vais
pouvoir agir sans violence alors de
quelle façon
j'ai pas été trop longue jupe
merci mon cher mon bon la chapelaude
merci oui écoutez je me suis dépêché
mais ça mérite pas une telle ne fait pas
semblant de ne pas comprendre royaume
c'est pour ça que je vous remercie mon
chèque 220 mille francs et vous ne me
connaissez que depuis trois semaines
mais jamais je n'aurais osé espérer de
votre part un geste aussi généreux aussi
spontanée c'était pour vous on ben
voyons
si ça n'avait pas été pour moi j'amène
ma femme n'avait osé accepté une somme
pareille
n'est ce pas juliette évidemment et puis
je vous connais si ça n'avait pas été
pour moi jamais vous n'auriez osella lui
proposer n'est ce pas la chapelaude
évidemment mais au moins est ce que ma
femme a bien sûr vous expliquer la
sphère sensationnel que je lance du
mieux que la pub il reste une des
jaunards avaient abattu voix juliette
c'est parce que je la connais pas encore
très haut mais avec ses 220 mille francs
mais vous allez gagner une fortune mais
vous en avez de la chance de commanditer
une pareille entreprise
c'est vous qui me remercierez un jour
réellement et que voulez-vous depuis le
premier jour je vous trouve tellement
sympathique
c'est pour ça que j'ai payé ma femme de
s'adresser à vous d'ailleurs à avant moi
je suis très sensible et bien nous
sommes servis mais ça vous pouvez après
le dîner je vous donnerai quelques
précisions mais bon cherchez pas la
peine je vous fais confiance envers nos
jardins que c'est une bonne idée est
bien établie effet l'exercice vous devez
avoir feint pas très
sa question qu'est ce que ça fait dire
bah c'est très clair tu as des dettes je
trouve qu'il est plus correct que ce
soit moi qui les paye et on sait pas une
blague tu lances une à former pour
qu'ils me prends tu aux écoutes ou quoi
déjà parlé un mois vis-à-vis de la
chapelotte eu mais dans une jolie
situation grave que ça lui qui m'avait
mis est ce que tu peux faire patienter
créanciers pendant trois mois on peut
toujours parfait et bien c'est tout ce
que je demande
alors c'est vrai qu'il a trouvé et oui
ma chérie évident c'est papa qui est
plutôt ça je n'en suis pas si sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quoi et oui
oui qui est elle attendez attendez plus
dans ton coin la jugeote devenir martin
fermé la porte à ce que j'entends rien
et qui accable voilà à l'eau qui est oui
ça y est je vous entends parfaitement
oui non monsieur non j'ai ben c'est une
erreur non vous n'avez pas à fournir la
preuve que votre déclaration intégrale
non voulait en fait que si vous ne
faites pas de déclaration de toute façon
c'est à votre contrôle de prouver
qu'elle est fausse sais pas vous mais
bien bas je me souviens parfaitement oui
je vous ai signé une une déclaration
pour 40000 francs de revenu oui veut
mais je sais bien que vous en dépensez
visiblement 300 milles mais puisque nous
sommes sûrs que vos bénéfices échappe à
tout contrôle
1 1 mais partons à non mais ça je dis
pas le contraire
votre contrôleur est en droit de vous
demander des explications à aram un kit
après eva vous lui répondez vous jouer
aux courses ou que je prends moi vous
êtes entré dans une vieille dame
un par une jeune ba si vous voulez moi
ça moi ça m'est égal
non mais j'avais d'une vieille parce que
c'était non mais je voulais pas vous
offenser ça vous plaît pas tant même
bateau je sais pas vous dîtes que vous
mangez votre capital ça c'est votre
droit le plus absolu ormes parfaite 9e
dit don mais je pense bien qu'il faut
pour tenir tête à ces gens là
d'ailleurs ils prennent la laine sur le
dos de ceux qui veulent bien se laisser
tondre vous savez comment demain à 3 et
attend et passez moi mon blog firmin
attendez je vous dis ça tout de suite
demain trois heures non ses prix après
demain j'ai rien de libre non plus je
n'ai rien avant jeudi 16h 45 jours ou
marques savent au vin très bien jeudi 16
à 45 mètres à gauche chère amie bon
tellement tout ça aux classes signé
maintenant vous serez gentille merci
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde au
salon dont une dizaine de personnes vous
allez bientôt jusqu'à huit heures avant
ce soir je regrette j'ai un dîner très
important je ferme à 7h30 quand je pense
que pendant 35 ans sur rester sans rien
faire
ça depuis six mois vous vous rattraper
un homme et je ne savais pas que c'était
aussi amusant travailler à l'eau oui
monsieur k busson qu'est ce que c'est
que ça qu'à 200 le contrôleur du fan de
ses marrons 10 amis ont passé le mois
fonctions par la suie la wii donné le
monsieur val qui va lui parler
donnez donnez allô bonjour oui ces cas
seront ralentis à l'appareil oui à
ladite d'or j'ai une bonne nouvelle à
vous apprendre un oui j'ai vu le
commandant du bureau de recrutement
alors c'est d'accord c'est arrangé un
votre grand fils aura son sursis mais
non mais non ne me remerciez pas c'est
l'amendé comment bien sûr bien sûr faux
qui finit ses études ce petit éloge ça
lui fait maintenant trente quatre ans
il
ça pousse à 1
oui eh bien écoutez je dis cet accord
voilà je vous remercie au revoir
monsieur qui a du sens et ben voila
voila quand ils souffrent des
déclarations de mes clients ils les
regardera pas trop près comment saura
tic a contribué avec votre client parce
que je mets un paraphe dans le haut de
la feuille à droite un tir ou est-ce que
vous avez préparé le texte pour le
transit survivent et le voilage l'airé
qui j'ai moi même temps les émois sa
français qui fait si bien les
déclarations d'amour pour quoi faire si
mal celle de vos revenus
c'est pas mal ce n'est pas l'état qui
vous aux primes c'est vous qui mais
connaissez-vous droit pour apprendre à
les connaître
venez à l'école des contribuables 104
que dû être s'était pas tant n'oubliez
pas de marquer ce numéro de téléphone
gentil si jamais ça se débattant voilà
de l'irma mettez ça sous enveloppe
c'est pourquoi j'attends le plus tôt
possible mais si on voulait me parler
oui j'ai dans mon bureau le docteur
gondrecourt vendre quoi tu as senti
quelque chose ce nom ait une grosse
envie quand elle veut il a des ennuis
avec son contrôleur et qui sait ce
contrôleur leur jacques laurent rousseau
l'con olala c'est un arriviste un
politique a alors je vais le voir
moi-même un lors jacques et puis je lui
dirai que le docteur gondrecourt et mon
client que je me tiens à sa disposition
pour lui montrer son livre mais que je
dois le prévenir amicalement qu'il y
trouvera le nom de la femme d'un haut
fonctionnaire qui s'est fait soigner
dernièrement pour une maladie
et bien vous allez vous voulez me parler
correspondre à la paix tout de suite
avant de recouvrir la l'idée n'est pas
mauvaise je vais là lui si vous m'aviez
chez vous que j'avais dit que j'allais
vous consulte alors je préfère le voir
moi-même parce qu'un grand médecin c'est
toujours bon à connaître au jury est
quelle bonne surprise avait quitté avec
giroud alors mais tu as bien fait mais
entre mon chéri comment vas tu fais
depuis ce matin moi tu déjeuner à la
maison tout ce à quoi je sais plus où
capuche et une simu en vitesse je sais
je suis descendu à 1h30 à 2h j'étais de
retour à tu vas tu es mon chéri c'est
possible mais maintenant quand je trouve
un chèque dans ton sac
il est signé deux mois gaston a montré
comment ça va très bien madame les
affaires marchent mettez en euros le
plaisir de ta visite mon amour y en a où
nous rassure toi non je suis moi je suis
passé la salle pleyel pour prendre des
fauteuils pour ce soir oui le récite à
deux pas des restes ou alors je suis
venue te demander si tu voulais venir
avec moi je suis désolé manche et adil
est très important auquel je ne peux pas
me soustraire
eh bien je demande la pop 1 chez lui là
bas les gens lui qui déteste la musique
ah oui mais il aime sa fille qu at il ce
bon monsieur fromentel au fait toujours
bien en colère contre moi à sa place
à propos vous n'avez jamais revu depuis
que vous êtes dans les affaires jamais
jamais dès que je lui ai annoncé que je
vais acheter le cabinet lubineau il m'a
chassé de marlon et il m'a donné sa
malédiction
ça vous a porté bonheur est alors
juliette le voit de temps en temps puis
elle s'arrange pour que la conversation
ne tombe pas trop sur moi sur moi non
plus chez soyez tranquille et vous croit
toujours à buenos aires parfait alors
arrangez vous pour que je ne revienne
jamais mais jamais bien compris
ce mystère là pourquoi est-ce que vous
ne lui avait pas dit carrément que vous
deveniez sous directeur de l'école des
contribuables par délicatesse on est à
prendre afin que son gendre et son
secrétaire l'ont trahi
il aurait eu un coup de sang cet homme
n'est donc est ce qu'il est bon pour ton
père et bat téléphone lui d'ici aux
fêtes
mais pour lui dire que tu dîne avec lui
ce soir ah oui un seul instant là je
vais voir le docteur a tout de suite que
je vous demande au numéro madame tout à
l'heure nous avons le temps dites-moi
giroux ça vous a réussi quitter papa
dans ma situation n'est pas comparable
non je pensais pas à l'argent
ça vous a réussi physiquement oui j'ai
pris une certaine élégance
et puis de l'autorité la désinvolture
sans vous déplaît au contraire je vous
aime mieux comme ça j'ai pas pas vous
étiez comment dirais-je un peu râpé un
peu armes yeux des débats j'étais un
fonctionnaire cjce terre à vous n'avez
pas changé
comment dois-je interpréter cela vous
savez bien je veux dire que vous êtes
toujours aussi aussi lumineuse aussi
complète
je vous donne pas son nom
je ne me plains pas et votre mari
c'est lui qui a changé non vous savez
que s'il continue comme ça les cols des
contribuables réalisera un million de
bénéfices la première année lesdites de
giroud vous devenez un beau party vous
moquez de moi mais pas loin et vous
rappelez vous cet été un soir à marlon
tout mon père regrettait de ne pas vous
avoir accepté pour jambes j'ai dit comme
lui je suis sûr que j'aurais été très
heureuse avec vous et vous me dites ça
maintenant vouloir et déjà dit ça nous
aurait guère avancé non c'est vrai et
puis aujourd'hui tout nous sépare de
mézin mari je suis son employé je lui
dois ma situation
puis le roi devient un riche il vous
rend heureuse n'est ce pas
maintenant il est parfait casto voyez
bien évidemment pas heureusement qu'on
ne se voit pas souvent
qu'est ce qui arriverait tout
seulement c'est mieux comme ça vous
disposez de très peu tôt comme tous les
sommes préoccupés et puis moi j'ai pas
une minute à moi comme toutes les femmes
qui n'ont rien à faire enfin bref c'est
inespéré comme ça nous n'aurons plus les
conversations la véraison
je crois aussi que c'est préférable à sa
radieuse présence illumine nos bureaux
obscures pour giroud toujours les mêmes
la chapelle basse que vous ça va nous
affaire à un monde fou dans
l'antichambre les da kg tap les
secrétaires s'empresse ce puits décosse
est une ruche en effet ça me fait penser
que je m'attarde et j'ai des clients à
recevoir vous m'excusez messieurs de la
chapelaude vous me laisser seul avec
madame val tube je vous excuse pas je
vous en remercie mes hommages tout
rêveuse aujourd'hui géré a mis la vie me
fait bon la chapelaude vous me regretté
qu'
toujours impitoyable et toujours
ravissante l'aude je rentre à faire écho
à ma femme l'a quitté
non mais c'est sans espoir vous savez
oui cet incorrigible avant d'écouter la
chapelaude la première fois que je vous
ai su recréer pour vous punir je vous ai
pris votre argent et bien cette fois ci
pour vous venir je vais vous le rendre
attendez attendez c'est pas parce que
j'ai fait la cour à madame baltique vous
voulez me le rend non non non non non
c'est parce que je touche 30% de vos
bénéfices parfait je pense que je vais
vous versez cette année 300 mille francs
parce que vous avez voulu me prendre ma
femme
moi je trouve ça immoral oui peut-être
peut-être mieux heureusement j'avais
escompté votre réussite est prévu
jusqu'au pub je vous rappelle que nous
avons signé un contrat pour dix ans et
que vous ne sauriez me rembourser avant
l'expiration de ce délai mais c'est
pourtant vrai vous savez faire vos
affaires vous aussi mon dieu jaloux de
la chapelaude il a élu mais presque
ravissante
ah bon et sa belle fille dort beaucoup
de plus que deux manches avez-vous son
armée vous êtes un homme très content et
tout paris sait pas mais non mais non
mais moi je ne savais pas mais jussiê le
savoir c'est d'elle que je viens vous
parler
bien parlé d'aller là pour moi
sherine ariana coup j'espère bien eh
bien je vais vous laisser
d'ailleurs il est sain que j'ai un
rendez vous marqué mais vous l'avez
rendu méfiant avec mon quoi au bois et
coûteux bouche que le point il est moins
loquace à deux pas d'ici sans adieu la
chapelaude puisque nous vous avons pour
dix ans ah oui non malheureusement
j'aurais pas le temps du séjour alors à
ce soir ce soit trop tard bon bah tu
sais tu vas au concert je serais rentré
avant toi diderot fait tu as eu ton père
oui nous permet déjà de son père mais je
crois que vous n'étiez plus en relation
fromentel à moi non mais elle va le voir
de temps en temps me dis alors mon bon
la chapelle qu'est ce qui vous arrive on
présume donc l'écouter le mois dernier
justement un soir je dînaient au
restaurant avec fra bat l tout à coup
bien petite heure ci nous dit-on l'achat
que je vous ai aperçu hier soir aux
variétés dans une avant-scène vous étiez
avec une bien jolie femme lui répond
sans malice mais je ne me cachais pas
fromentel à mon âge quand on prend une
détresse c'est surtout pour la montrer
oui en effet pas exclusivement
enfin surtout ainsi votre maîtresse mme
di fromentel mes compliments elle a fait
une fourrure et des bijoux splendide
voilà une personne qui doit vous coûter
cher et moi je continue toujours aussi
agile du mans mais mon cher je lui donne
50 mille francs par mois diable s'écrit
faut maintenant je peux pas faire mois
avant d'être avec moi elle était avec le
groupe open à hymer qu'il entretenait
sur ce pied la tiens tiens si du
fragmentaires et comment s'appelle cette
ravissante personnes meti d'orange joli
nom et elle habite avec vous la
chapelaude non fromentel réplique âge
toujours sans comprendre vous voulez
revenir
betty possède un ravissante hôtel
particulier 27 avenue henri martin et là
dessus je vois votre beau-père qui prend
des notes sur un carnet à l'orge du
bassin fromentin mais qu'est ce qui vous
prend pour que vous inscrivez comme ça
que le nom et l'adresse de ma maîtresse
est ce que vous auriez envie de me l'a
soufflée par hasard gaston écoutez bien
ce qui me répond nous
non non elle je veux seulement jeté un
coup d'oeil sur sa déclaration de
revenus mais non mais c'est une idée
fixe
et qu'est ce qu'elle avait déclaré hier
alors évidemment mon bon père a dû la
taxer d'office et lui flanquer un rappel
jeu sans bill francs pour l'année
dernière et pour les trois années
précédentes total 800 mille formé dit
d'elle elle doit être épouvante et non
pas du tout elle m'a passé la feuille en
disant mon pauvre chérie c'est embêtant
ce qui t'arrive là et b en effet à
tanger pour ça que je viens vous bah moi
je veux pas plus de 8000 francs
d'abord je le suis avec betty que depuis
4 noir alors ça me choque d'être
imposées sur des revenus qu'elle s'est
faite en couchant avec un dos bonjour je
trouve ça inadmissible
ben écoute et envoyez-la feuillage
tottenham l anomie des rennais et puis
attention il est resté avec betty que
pendant ton nom alors faut que j'aille
rechercher tous les hommes qui ont
entretenu bâti depuis quatre ans que je
les réunissent en assemblée générale
on fasse une répartition non non non il
vaut bien mieux qu'on s'arrange tous les
trois tous les trois ou tweets ou d'être
un nom avec betty je lui donner rendez
vous ici à 5 heures elle doit être dans
le salon data je vais vous la présenter
je suis sûr que sa présence va vous
inspirez vous allez voir que
mademoiselle matinaux
enjeu même te manquer de respect je suis
pas sûr que ce soit tout à fait que ça
fait plus gaston vallier directeur de
l'école des contribuables enchanté une
demoiselle messier je le trouve très
gentil oui oui mais c'est pas pour ça
que je t'ai fait venir
il s'agit de thézac pour un oui alors le
suit vous a raconté
vous vous rendez compte de ce qui
m'arrive de cent mille francs par an
cette année encore je fais que l'achat
peut que c'est lui qui paye ça va mais
il est plus bien jeune
tu peux mourir tellement courageux pas
faire ça tu peux te le champ d'à et
alors où est ce que je vais les trouver
ces deux cent mille francs oui je sais
je suis jeune et je plais bien
mais il ya la crise si tous les hommes
sont ruinés à que ça me servira de
plaire à l'écouté des temps des moments
essayez-vous
voilà calmez vous l'année dernière
j'étais avec jade a peiné mais il avait
dit mieux je pouvais me croire bien
tranquille est bas en trois semaines il
a été nettoyée il s'était mis à la
hausse sur le dollar non mais je vous
demande alors oui ça ce n'était pas une
bonne idée pour monsieur que la
situation des femmes devient difficile
par les temps qui courent c'est encore
chez nous quelques de chômeuses et les
industries de luxe évidemment nous
représentons luxe dans toute l'acception
du terme
prenez un type qui a une maison de
campagne une automobile une femme
légitime qu à domestiquer une maîtresse
il veut faire des économies qu est ce
qui supprime d'abord sa maîtresse
c'est la chose qui lui est moins utile
c'était très juste et très intelligent
ah oui
les actrices encore où les mannequins
enfin celles qui ont un métier à côté
elle s'en tire mais nous autres qui nous
consacrons uniquement aux hommes qui
nous choisissent au je vous ai fait un
monsieur que notre destinée de lien
tragique voulant fabretti enfin je suis
toujours là mais le veau le veau d'or
est toujours debout mais tenez monsieur
ma soeur gabrielle davies ya encore
trois ans à deauville elle faisait des
banques aux deux cent mille francs et à
ecouché que le roi d'espagne
encore une qui pouvait se dire j'ai pas
à m'en faire eh ben vous connaissez la
suite des événements alphonse xiii a
perdu sa situation comme les autres et
ma soeur jodie francs à la boue langues
o ne nous faisons pas d'illusions
l'heure est grave
oui mais dites moi comment se fait-il
que
vous n'ayez jamais produit de
déclaration d'impôts mais moi je savais
même pas ce que c'est on m'a toujours
laissé tranquille et il a fallu que ce
vieil étourneaux dîne avec le directeur
des contributions à la bienvenue
monsieur fromentel il a presque grisy
pour faire parler
quel vieux de bambi sur petit jeu c'est
son beau-père
non mais ça fait rien continuer au
contraire à mes amis
quelqu'un nous allons fait et ben
écoutez c'est pas sorcier 1 on vous
attaque c'est d'officieux 800 millions
de de revenus et ben tout bêtement parce
que c'est la somme que la chapelaude a
indiqué à fromentel tournée il peut
s'être trompé il peut reparler
étourdiment dans les vapeurs de
l'ivresse l'écart info qui nous prouve
que vous avez reçu de telles sommes
vous ne tenez pas de comptabilité
j'espère que vous ne donnez pas encore
de reçus à vos amants n'ont jamais
jamais venu à l'idée
alors pardon il ya des signes extérieurs
betija sont l'hôtel sa vie de la cades
des frais évident et bien moi je
prétendrait que depuis quatre ans
mademoiselle d'orange n'a reçu aucune
somme de qui que ce soit et on demandera
tragédie qu'il est bien vous répondrais
mes économies
ça n'allait pas aaaaah faudra pas le
dire sa vie et moi il y a quatre ans
vous avez fait la connaissance d'un
prince égyptien n'a qui vous a donné
métaux 60 millions en 3 mois marque le
combat n'est pas pourquoi il ya quatre
ans et parce qu'au delà de 3 ans
l'administration ne peut rien vous
réclamez donc ça c'est la bc de la
grande guerre fiscale
et qu'est-ce qui est devenu mon prince
alors vous l'avez quittée parce qu'ils
étaient brutales dans ses colères comme
dans ces étreintes
vous comprenez non bon il a pris un
petit être frais et sains il a laissé
une véritable bloc est effrayant mérimée
oui mais oui c'est effrayant parce que
vous avez mis quatre ans à reconquérir
votre belle santé
parce que pendant quatre ans ce fut le
repos forcé la vertu implacable et
improductive
l'art est désastreux de toute activité
professionnelle je comprends et comme
les frais étaient les mêmes nous avons
subi un déficit d'exploitation
il est impensable qu'on ne nous donne
rêve pas il est très fin qui bat en
direct dont le
cette année il faudra pas oublier de la
faire de déclaration d'abord parce que
vous êtes signal et ensuite parce que
votre liaison officielle avec la
chapelaude marque une reprise évidente
de veau aux activités activités oui
alors que coupet galaxie ans et mettons
alors à votre avis combien faut-il que
je déclare et bien compter 300 mille
francs de revenus par an mais qu'est ce
qu'on va me prendre les pieds mais
attendez attendez on va déjà déduire les
frais professionnels
les frais professionnels en quoi
peuvent-ils consistait et d'année le
coiffeur la manucure le masseur les
bains de soleil le maquillage ne s'est
pas voilé faut aussi le rouge à lèvres
sont pas obligés de les avoir tandis que
mademoiselle d'orange
elle ne saurait les éviter mais sa
profession et de plaire donc tout ce
qu'elle dépense pour mettre sa beauté en
valeur devient incontestablement des
frais professionnels jacques tallineau
j.chirac aussi dicté à jouer comme ça
sur une feuille d'un concours est une
fan canaux et moi j'ai pas préjuger pour
migrer moins payés en parlons et pour
combien les comptes et vous les femmes
professionnelles 20 60 voix non mille
comme 60 mille francs
mais nous si on admet le principe c'est
pas énorme mais attendez on va encore
trouver autre chose si je dirigeais la
longueur qui me coûte très cher
non non non jamais c'est très défendable
ce qu'elle dit là mais oui un petit
jeune homme robuste qui s'occupe d'elle
qui lui tient ses comptes qui la
conseille enfin tout ce que fait mars
tout ce que fait max pour gabriel ma
soeur oui c'est ça monsieur pelletier
vous êtes un homme épatant qu'est-ce qui
vous doit on bat santé qui s'avale déjà
tous âges pour rédiger une déclaration
détaillée et puis après on verra
qu'est ce que c'est un lien de monsieur
fromentel demande si le cheval qui peut
le recevoir
comment tu es mon beau père et nous
sommes passés mais que ce qu'il vient
faire ici
je ne sais pas une mais la patte moi je
veux pas qu'ils nous trouvent et ce
n'est pas non plus très bien le fisc
donc enfilé par l'afrique et surtout
n'oubliez pas ma déclaration détaillée
apporter la moins chez moi je serai seul
on prendra le porto vous est conté mort
mais non mais non frais professionnels
le gentil oui et puis allez pas farouche
évidemment j'aurais mieux aimé votre
choix
on fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut non
plus aux entraînements
mon beau père chez moi alors ça c'est un
mauvais vous disposez de quatre vingt
mille francs
comment vous avez besoin d'argent nos
sources si j'en avais besoin et pas à
vous que je m'adresserai je viens vous
demander cordialement et dans votre seul
intérêt si vous pouvez mettre 80 mille
francs dans une affaire superbe dont
vous deviendrez le coût direct à la
drôle d'idée mais qu'à la fin les
salines dumontier qui ont une usine à
concarneau des bureaux à paris et qui
compte deux cent mille francs par an les
donne c'est pas mal on l'ignoré pas que
dumontier mon amiet teambuy se fait
vieux il cherche elle associe actif
entre points non vous êtes l'homme qu'il
lui faut je vous apporte une occasion
unique sous 18 mai bonjour mon père
c'est ma bonjour monsieur
que pensez vous de la proposition je ne
les attendais pas je vous vois une fois
tous les six mois et là vous
réapparaissez en me demandant de me
faire marchands de sardines qu'est-ce
qu'il faut prendre le temps que j'allais
h et coll médicaux vous il serre ses
mixes la bouffe et que je suis là le
rouge chaque jour on vous être
dangereuse si on a appris en haut lieu
que le thé nancy de l'écho des
contribuables imiter mon propre engendre
que la file monsieur fromentel du
directeur des contributions vive est
allègrement des zones soustraites au
fisc
vous rendez vous compte de ce que vous
faites je suis la risée de toute
administration via trois jours le
directeur général m'a fait appelé et m'a
dit qu'il devenait urgent pour moi que
vous trouviez notre situation avoue ne
sait trop tard robert moi mon affaire et
lancer maintenant elle marche très bien
dans ont regagné plus d'un million cette
année c'est révoltant mais vous vous
dressez comprenais pas vous êtes un
insurgé a révolutionné pas du tout je
respecte scrupuleusement la loi mais
tant pis pour vous s'il ya des fissures
moi je passe au travers
d'ailleurs j'ai rien inventé vous savez
il y en a beaucoup d'autres que moi qui
font ce métier oui mais s'ils ne sont
pas le champ de monsieur fromentel
puisque tout ça c'est pour votre fille
ma femme elle est heureuse elle n'a plus
de dettes je peux enfin subvenir aux
besoins de mon ménage mais assez criant
que c'était mon devoir 1 alors que
juliette est heureuse vous en est sûr
est ce que vous insinuez là croyez-moi
montjean traiter avec mon ami dumontier
est passé une partie de l'année à
concarneau
tout le monde y trouvera son profit
alors fine élégante jolie comme elle et
vous vous verriez votre fille mariée un
marchand de sardy jeu face à trèbes et
bien parler lui ans le soir vous verrez
ce qu'elle vous dira ce soir puisque
elle dîne avec vous vous ne saviez pas
et vous appâter les fans est qu en 2008
your own c'est parce que vous n'étiez
pas à votre bureau
ces jeunes arrivent alors je comprends
moi je comprends elle vous a dit qu'elle
dînait avec mahiedine avec à l'autre ça
ne m'étonne pas vous allez être cocus
encore
mes côtés je lui donne tout l'argent
qu'elle me demande un wind elle sait
d'où vient cet argent elle en a honte
et comme elle vous méprise le chef de
l'état vous êtes atteint d'aberrations
professionnelle de 1 à moins que ce ne
soit parti pour vilaine pour vinaver
villennes sur seine près de poissy
elle va très souvent à mes la contrée
dégagent une poésie qui l'attirent
qu'est ce que vous allez encore me
raconter le percepteur de menthe
monsieur mouche que je connais qui fait
du canotage à ses heures de loisirs a
croisé ma fille plusieurs fois sur le
fleuve elle était assise à l'arrière
d'un canot automobile qu'un jeune homme
brun dirigé cheveux au vent en lui
récitant défaire alors comme le
percepteur demande c'est que je voulais
il est venu tout de suite vous raconter
la chose et là même précisé qu'à sa
dernière promenade de juliette portait
un chapeau rouge
vous êtes vraiment à peyrens pharming un
bureaucrate intoxiqués par 35 ans de
rigorisme administrative l'action le
succès de mon entreprise vous exaspère
l'homme vous n'hésitez pas calomnier
votre fille pour que je divorce et que
vous puissiez enfin la mariée un
directeur des contributions vous ne
croyez pas non plus histoire de chapeau
rouge et de petit bateau blanc le sait
vraiment trop puéril vous savez à votre
place je trouve autre chose moi dupont
au revoir beau père dender vous n'avez
vraiment pas de chance hein pour une
fois que vous venez me voir non
seulement je garde ma femme qui est
fidèle mais mon entreprise qui est
superbe
je voudrais vous poser une dernière
question fait aussi peu de temps au
diabète vous avez acquis cette soudaine
compétences et ce goût de la
comptabilité la noblesse de certaines
missions peuvent parfois inspiré un
homme vrai mais surtout si l'essai
s'adjoindre de bons conseillers des
canailles pour travailler chez nous des
fraudeurs comme kong de son plus
redoutable adversaire
elles ont avoué que vous avez débaucher
l'un des nôtres quelques contrôleurs en
retraite qui nous a vendu son âme mais
je ne vois pas du tout ce que vous
voulez dire monsieur
elle est pas de pardon les séjours
civile de suite
je croyais que vous êtes à buenos aires
quand je suis revenu la traversée a été
bonne mais bon vous l'avez trahir en
quoi vous n'avez jamais quitté paris
pardon pardon au jour de l'an je vais
donner trois jours de congé il a été à
l'image voir sa maman
voilà pourquoi vous m'avez donné votre
démission vous à l'ancien fonctionnaire
vous que la france a revu de ces deniers
ont tous passé dans le camp de ceux qui
la découvrent en patron je suis entré
chez votre gendre parce que c'est votre
fils papa
je m'égare trahit pas mon genre trahi
par mon secrétaire je suis excusé de
plein de contrôle de mes idées je m'en
tire mais nous voilà bientôt à la fin
février
je vais la regarder votre déclaration
et ce n'est pas conforme à ce que vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure à part dans
pardon tout à l'heure je parlais à mon
bon père mais officiellement la maison
ne gagne que 150 mille fois par an pire
accroc veux moi le contraire je suis
drac caverne d'ali baba
on sent sous le coup d'une dernière
stupéfaction voilà dix minutes que nous
causons j'ai toujours mon portefeuille
il est tout à fait en colère plus encore
que vous devez penser parce qu'il m'a
dit des choses dites 2e giroud quand
vous êtes resté seul avec ma femme
solaire est ce qu elle a téléphoné à son
père je ne sais pas j'ai quitté ma laval
qui s est vite je vais vous poser une
question mme giroux vous qui le
connaissez bien carla vous étiez déjà le
secrétaire de fromentel quand j'ai
épousé sa fille depuis deux ans qu'est
ce que vous pensez d'elle quelle
singulière question jeudi à ce qu'est ce
que vous avez l'impression que je ne
rends pas heureuse qu'elle a un autre
homme en tête ça monsieur zh avec les
femmes on ne peut jamais savoir
mais alors elle elle me trompe
ah non ah non monsieur madame 20 kg est
incapable de vous tromper
c'est une épouse irréprochable et jamais
été plus convaincus qu'aujourd'hui
enjeux de pourquoi aujourd'hui parce que
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui elle m'a
parlé de vous en des termes si
affectueux si émouvant ce m'a dit que
vous étiez parfait a textuellement enfin
en bas je vous remercie et yappa quoi
c'est enseigner
mais pourquoi cette subite inquiétudes
n'ont rien c'est le la visite de ce que
tartuffe live qui m'avez vous avez reçu
beaucoup de monde mais il n'y a plus
qu'une personne au salon très bien fait
la rentrée tout de suite
moyon 17h40 on va l'expédier invitation
cette dernière personne
j'ai voulu à qui ai-je l'honneur de
parler mon nom que vous connaissez
peut-être et pierre sérigny bien sérigny
les arts les balais mécaniques mais non
monsieur sérigny le poète l'homme de
lettres partante
je suis l'auteur de la coupe qui déborde
de l'homme couché et de mélusine en
vacances qui a eu un certain
retentissement
je pense bien son pied pierre e sérignan
mais je suis enchantée monsieur vous
aimez mélusine excusez moi monsieur j'ai
si peu le temps de lire et évidemment
voilà ce qui rend notre coeur guerre si
difficile la vie fiévreuse des temps
présents n'incite pas à la lecture
enfin le ferry les vrais artistes ne se
décourage pas à vous nous préparer
quelque chose de nouveau mais oui
l'étude d'un cas troublants
d'homosexualité je vous enverrai le
volume dès sa parution
alors vous êtes bien aimable mais celui
là je le lirai de mon voile à je vous
écoute il s'agit d'une femme c'est lisse
est férié marié va avec enfin elle a des
revenus personnels
aa je ne sais pas monsieur ça je ne sais
pas du tout non elle est blonde et les
sensuelles et elle voudrait aimer les
hommes mais une force mystérieuse et
puissante l'en empêche son enveloppe
frêle et diaphane elle sent bouillonner
de la masculinité est implacablement
l'homme qui est en elle la pousse vers
les femmes
[Musique]
voyez vous ça oui d'ailleurs l'oeuvre a
pour titre le mal dont j'ai souffert
c'est très joli leur prénom ses astra
normaux c'est keith et entreprend la
conquête d'un jeune italien elle s'offre
à lui
mais lui ne la prend pas car lui n'aime
que les hommes à percevez vous la
situation angoissante dans laquelle j'ai
plongé mais 2-0 en toute affaire
alors quand ces 17 comprend cette
tragique infortune elle négocie avec
puisque vous allez m'envoyer le volume 1
laissez-moi la surprise d'ailleurs je ne
supporte pas que ce soit pour me
raconter votre nouveau roman que vous
avez pris la peine de venir chez moi
en effet il s'agit de choses infiniment
plus prosaïque de la déclaration de
mézin à la bonne heure on m'a dit votre
singulière compétences et que vous me
facilite résultat chaque fois je ne
comprends je fais de mon mieux pour
préserver les intérêts de mes clients
mon ambition est de devenir le mot
pendant c'est très flatteur mais nous
disons dans paul série mais non monsieur
pierre le pole man ballet mécanique vous
êtes mariés et aux célibataires
très bien alors profession homme de
lettres qu'est ce que vous gagnez 100
mille francs par an c'est bien ça mes
oeuvres me rapporte dix mille et ma
fortune personnelle 90001 bombe à voir
comme ça je comprend mieux alors les
aux éditeurs les déclare certainement
donc impossible de ne pas les mentionner
n'est pas bon quand à vos rentes en quoi
consiste-t-elle dénominatif non aux
porteurs dont incontrôlable alors nous
mettrons 30000 1 j'ai aussi quelques
droits d'auteur comme onfray d'amérique
vous les recevez directement
bon alors on n'en parle pas âgé
également une vieille tante l'achat
johannes de sérigny qui depuis ma
naissance m'envoie 25000 font jour de
leurs bombes en on parle enfin
ah bon ah j'oubliais monsieur j'ai un
peu d'argent dans une banque de
rotterdam
n'en parlons pas on parle de rien alors
si on parle mais il est inutile d'être
bavard
ah bon vous avez des propriétés j'ai une
petite maison de campagne
qu'est-ce qu'elles vont eux il ya deux
ans on en a offert 150 me on va
aujourd'hui environ 75 donc c'est tout
je crois très bien et bien nous allons
rédiger tout ça monsieur votre adresse
117 rue de vaugirard sont 17 rue de
vaugirard mais à la campagne
villa mélusine à vilaine
[Musique]
villennes sur seine oui près de poissy
vous connaissez est en vogue mambé j'ai
dit qu'un parce que tout à l'heure
quelqu'un m'en parlait justement votre
villa est au bord de l'eau à le jardin
des sens jusqu'à la berge c'est à l'un
de mes tilleuls que jamar mon bateau
vous avez un bateau oui un canot
automobile
ah j'oubliais il faut peut-être en
parler et oui je crois que nous allons
en parler
vous savez ce n'est pas à iasi c'était
un yatch quatre places et amateurs de 10
pour les jours devant ce jeu mais la
voile et vous y allez souvent cela a dit
len j'habite
oui je passe guère que trois ou quatre
mois à paris comme jean-jacques il n'y a
que la nature qui m'inspire à sa fin je
vous vois très bien mais bien entendu
que vous faites des promenades dans
votre bateau oui ou réciter des vers
offrir cheveux au vent puis vous les
réciter à la personne qui est dans le
bateau quelquefois une jeune femme
blonde avec un grand chapeau rouge
vous m'avez vu il ya quelques jours avec
mon ami monsieur mouche
le contrôleur de menthe jeu cas notaient
et nous vous avons croisé oui c'est vous
je vous reconnais maintenant c'était
bien vous en voilà une amusante
coïncidence entre est amusant mais elle
est votre maîtresse là la femme au
chapeau rouge est pas encore mais je
crois qu'elle se donnera bientôt
elle m'a parlé de jeudi prochain
c'est une adorable avant tout alors vous
voulez vous ma pierre antoine le
coiffeur et prier ma femme de revenir
ici immédiatement ils méritent de
madonna bah oui évidemment mais il se
fait pas et non non je vous en prie j'ai
encore besoin de quelques détails sur
les dates ma fortune non non sur cette
adorable avant la date serait que pour
moi ne croyez pas ça monsieur vous savez
mais mes journées se passent en
conversation d'affaires alors je suis
tellement content quand je peux composer
avec un véritable intellectuel un homme
d'imagination et puis cela ne peut que
vous faire plaisir monsieur mouche et
moi même l'avons trouvée délicieuse
cette jeune personne n'en suis pas sûr
je vous remercie monsieur de donner
ainsi l'occasion de parler d'internement
ces chiffres ces hommes pauvres
alors je les ai rencontrés pour la
première fois à la comédie française
un jeudi en matinée ont joué au d'aucune
elle occupait le fauteuil 47 et moi le
strapontin fbi ce qui est tout content
elle était seul paraissait sans du
billet ne pas comprendre très bien la
pièce alors à l'entracte je la lui
expliquer on se figure à tort que
cléopâtre en inscrire car elle n'y est
pas du tout pas du tout aussi parce
qu'elle elle ses fils qu'elle a envie
euros de gains non parce qu'elle les
aime d'amour son cas d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus pathétique que celui lefebvre est
alors quand on vient me dire que racine
a voulu faire un parallèle
nous nous égarons je me laisse emporter
à la fin de la représentation elle m'a
permis de lui a fait une tasse de thé
chez un pâtissier
là nous avons bavardé je lui ai dit des
verts chez le pâtissier
oui les a trouvés très beau alors je me
suis écrié en madame si vous m'entendez
voulait dire sur mon bateau sous le ciel
à villaines il vous paraîtrait plus beau
encore naturellement à l'avenir les la
nano sur l'angle et vous l'avez revue
souvent de temps à autres suivant son
caprice elle arrive sans le prévenir
nous bavardons des heures elle s'en va
quand elle veut et le croiriez vous
monsieur je ne sait rien d'elle que son
prénom
juliette c'est bien vague mène
maintenant et pourquoi cette incognito
je suppose que c'est par égard pour son
mari à elle est mariée et ruiné mais
dont entretien qu'elle avait épousé un
de ces hommes d'affaires qui ne
s'occupent pas de leurs femmes et
calabre incessants accaparé des primes
will power elle vient
merci vous voyez monsieur je suis
importe vous en prie je vous en prie au
contraire je bénis le hasard qui vous a
amenée chez ce n'est pas le hasard
monsieur c'est elle oui avant-hier comme
nous suivions le fils de noël s'est
écrié brusquement
vous savez que vous n'en avait plus que
pour huit jours pour quoi faire et je
répondu pour faire votre déclaration de
revenus j'avoue que j'ai été surpris
cette jeune femme qui se promènent en
bateau avec un homme qu'il aime et à
laquelle une idée pareille vient à
l'esprit
oui at elle est la fille d'un directeur
des contributions c'est peut-être
l'imagination vous aussi noir que vous
croyez monsieur alors c'est elle qui
vous a dit venir me voir une vie comme
je lui disais combien ces affaires
massom elle me dit pourquoi n'allez-vous
pas demandez conseil à monsieur valtier
il vous arrange race en cinq minutes et
bien effectivement nous allons vous
arranger ça en cinq minutes
nous allons la rédiger votre déclaration
d'impôts et tout de suite parce que je
ne voudrais pas vous faire perdre de
temps j'ai dans l'idée que vous dîner ce
soir avec un et puis nous allons
entendre pas des redskins
alors droit d'auteur 10000 revenus 90000
vos disciples mettrions 30 j'ai réfléchi
c'est impossible l'achat d'un dess 10000
les droits d'auteur d'amérique combien
je croyais que l'on parle haut et fort
ce serait dangereux ou lampard que je
vous conseille de me dire la vérité un
mille dollars par an ça fait vingt-cinq
mille francs
le dollar a baissé il remonte et
rotterdam pour parle de tout alors on
reparle de tout deux cent mille francs
par an à 10 % ça fait mal mais ça ne
leur apporte pas discours tant pis pour
vous si vous ne savez pas faire vos
affaires
le fisc n'a pas à en souffrir la maison
de vilaines robot au havre chère celle
là trois cent mille s'assure que vous
avez dit 75 mais je ne savais pas
qu'elle était au bord de l'eau sa
quadruple sa valeur quant au bateau
alors là le bateau à il n'a pas de prix
le bateau 25 % de majoration comme
célibataire et aucune personne autre
chance a fait dix mille selon eux faire
beaucoup d'argent car oui oh oui ça me
sentirai avec 65 mille francs comment
mais l'année dernière j'en ai payé 15 me
voyais tranquille on vous fera un rappel
et si c'est une maison sérieuse
monsieur je ne tolère ni les fraudes ni
la dissimulation du tout du tout au
contraire
[Musique]
alors alors quoi tu ne dis pas bonjour à
monsieur monsieur je ne connais pas
allons voyons road aucune le pâtissier
villennes sur seine le bateau jsk ou
compte a dit alors tu dîner avec lui ce
soir
et tu ne connais pas je dîne avec papa
tu as téléphone hier de baisse et la
firme le contraire qui ça n'empêche
j'avais papa oui pousse à essayer
puisque les métairies sinon l'heure
n'est pas la question est elle alors le
cynisme de cette femme et passe tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer
mais revient lui et lui qui ne sait pas
mentir lui qui n'est qu'un homme
brillant ne l'est déjà plus parle vous
êtes souffre au monsieur oui non c'est à
dire si je suis un peu ému je ne sais
pas du tout pourquoi parce que je n'ai
pas du tout l'honneur ne vous connaît
joly fait pas tout ce que tu ne crois
pas qu'il serait plus élégant de ma voit
tout de suite que tué sa maîtresse
non monsieur je vous ai dit la vérité
c'était pour jeudi
tu as entendu qu'est ce tu veux c'est un
poète il n'est pas trop fort ce bon eh
bien je crois que nous n'avons plus rien
à nous dire
en effet j'ajoute que simone veil qui
avait pris la précaution de me dire quel
était votre femme vous n'auriez pas à
raconter tout ça soyez soyez en sûr au
revoir madame blanche
adieu série est évidemment au revoir
monsieur van tinh je suis trucy fier qui
aurait pensé qu une si merveilleuse île
et ben vous pourrez toujours en faire un
livre
vous n'aurez qu'à ont changé le
dénouement cesse vous en donne ma parole
le poète possédera la belle inconnue
dans le bateau eh ben voilà
quant à ma déclaration quelqu'un d'autre
s'en chargera oui ça vaut mieux
tous les points de vue
oh la la c'est désagréable tous à ce que
je suis embêté moi oui je comprends ça
avec qui n'est jamais seul la gueule à
présent
voilà tout ce qui toquent mais ma parole
je lis tu n'es tu est inconsciente
enfin je pense surtout à des choses qui
me démonte tu me portent sur la tête un
petit mazurie état seule préoccupation
de savoir comment tu vas passer ta
soirée petit dîner avec tu sais bien que
non alors ça priest et du fait qu'un
homme travaille il ne s'ensuit pas
nécessairement que sa femme doivent ce
mal conduit ce mal conduit mais enfin
voyons gaston réfléchi cij avait attaché
la moindre importance aux rêveries de ce
point est est ce que je leur envoyais
est ce que je lui aurais vente et à
compétence fiscale et une astuces sont
surtout que tu a agi par étourderie et a
parlé de ses impôts et toi machinalement
tu lui as du rab amoureuse n'irai pas
voir monsieur gaston volts et en
oubliant complètement tu m as far ou
gaston comme tum juges tu regardé un peu
de sévérité pour toi même tu sais qu'est
ce que tu me reproches je ne te donne
pas tout ce qu'il te faut ce que tu ne
me donnes pas gaston c'est ta présence
c'est la sollicitude constante d'une
femme a besoin je te vois je nageais
tout en une seule
l'engagement de huit mois et n'importe
comment chercher
ainsi le voilà le dilemme est faux bien
je m'occupe de toit du matin au soir je
ne gagne pas d'argent et tu me trompes
or en avoir ou bien jean gagnent donc je
suis occupé et tu me trompes parce que
je te délaisse alors là on n'en sortira
jamais s'il ya peut-être une solution
didon et si tu travaillais toi aussi et
même si tu devenais ma collaboratrice
ici mais lui ici comme ça ne se
quitteraient plus et puis la question
fiscale de te stresse étrangères qu'à
tout autre voyons fille d'un homme qui
près sur les contribuables femme d'un
homme qui les défend tu serais tu serais
en affaires depuis que tu es au monde
qui n'a entendu parler que d'un pont à
oui ça c'est vrai d'ailleurs j'ai des
papas quand j'étais jeune fille est ben
oui mais tu sais il faudra sérieux
apprentissage et vins et mets giro est
la girouette
laissez vos jauges penser qu elle écoute
on va lui annoncer ça tout de suite
allez vous voulez vous faire monter
jusque chez vous s'il vous plaît
comment qui usent à nos jours soit plus
destine york à il tombera salon bombe a
fait monter chez vous dis donc qu'est ce
que j'ai donné comme un point commun à
bab et vous me demandez patron oui j
vous vous avez beaucoup de travail
moi aussi que diriez vous de nous
adjoindre une collaboratrice une femme
rhône
nous faisons un métier qui ne convient
guère à une femme vivait il s'agit de la
mienne a alors c'est autre chose et même
valtier accepterait et giroud la femme
sambre est elle ne voit jamais alors
nous allons la mettre au courant de nos
affaires enfin vous surtout vous ferez
pour est ce que vous avez fait pour moi
mais avec plaisir monsieur et baba
l'instant là je vais je veux voir sur un
joueur de destiny je regarde en 5 min du
matin ma chérie aubin suis bien content
maintenant tu vas être ici du matin au
soir et balla je suis tranquille
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est
lui celui qui a eu cette idée à gerland
nous allons nous voir tous les jours
toute la journée
oui madame madame pour gaston il a
vraiment pas de choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là c'est le grand salon voyez là
c'est la salle de billard et laura
c'était une terrasse alors je vais
fermer sur trois côtés le feu de salle à
manger comme ça c'est un délicieux
déjeuner en famille lui mozart et tous
bleus là qu'est ce que c'est
c'est la mer méditerranée mais ça au cap
d'ail je m'en doutais que cet immense la
main à bazou croire
non je parle deval patrick à 3000 mètres
au hockey ce que vous avez payé comme
impôts fonciers vous informer rien du
tout non non la grille d'entrée dépend
de la commune de cap d'ail mais la
maison et tout le jardin sont en
territoire monégasque
vous savez que dans la principauté de
monaco personnes le pédagogue mon pays
non je dis à 10 mètres carrés en france
non je m'en tirerais avec 45 francs
d'impôts par an et encore et encore je
les contesterai peut-être à tomber elle
est extraordinaire
on va écouter nous défendrons assez les
intérêts de nos clients m'ont permis d
autres voilà votre unique préoccupation
il est équitable que cette grandeur
d'âme vous est permis en 14 mois
d'acheter ou champs-elysées ce
magnifique capable d'y transférer vos
bureaux et vos appartements dame a déjà
fondé huit succursales en province et de
réaliser des bénéfices astronomiques
alors et quel goût toucher 30 % la
chapelaude il d apathie j'ai rêvé 30
soumet à propos q qu'est ce que m'a dit
mademoiselle irma ce matin nous avons la
tour eiffel
oui le contrat était similaire avec la
ville de paris à partir du 1er janvier
c'est notre firme donc les lettres de
feu fascineront tout par l'école des
contribuables c'est bien long comment
avez vous disposez ça ben verticalement
ont bien sûr
j'avais d'abord pensé à faire réhausser
la tour mais
j'ai quand même de gros frais voyez
alors nous apparaîtrons deux fois à un
premier allumage les colts est
évidemment les gens sont intrigués et sa
garde
l'école dé quoi
et pouf ça c'est un foyer à la deuxième
allumage contribuables et sur les quatre
faces qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa
tôle érigées de notre chiffre d'affaires
lui permet d'augmenter légèrement le
budget publicité regarder comme ça parce
que votre cas m'attriste une des plus
jolies femmes de paris passant sa vie
sur des chiffres moi moi c'est à faire
pleurer mais que voulez vous autrefois
le contribuable n'était pas différent
parce que je ne le connaissais pas
maintenant je me suis penché sur sa
misère et je lève
oui parfois même son amour aveugle un
peu trop dernièrement dans une
déclaration elle a déduit des dettes de
jeu
je ne fais pas ton affaire et je
n'aimerais mieux que je reprenne ma vie
d'autre part de tout mon coeur jusqu'ici
nous oui qui est ahronot la con qui
montent pas celui là nous aurons laissez
le en bas oh là là mes enfants à rolle
bord-champ stone est vrai que six heures
l avocat américain
c'est lydie par l'union des
contribuables des états unis éblouie par
nos résultats ils sont venus demander à
gaston de passer quelques mois à new
york et y fonder une maison dans ce cas
là qu'est ce que vous avez répondu bah
que j'allais réfléchir parce que c'est
une affaire qui ne me tente pas beaucoup
je connais pas bien les lois américaines
alors je lui ai prié de revenir mais je
prends un très bien ce que je vais lui
dire eh bien vous voulez vous que j'y
aille
trois mêmes jeux je dirais doit passer
dans 48 heures oui c'est une bonne idée
ça se faire prier ça fait toujours bien
bon alors est ce qu on a tout de suite
bien il est trois heures je vais
descendre aussi je suis ceux qui
attaquent clients qui m'attend rocha le
bétonne à l'école des contribuables vous
est évidemment celle qui appelle le plus
la déclaration
côté qu'est ce que c'est monsieur
fromentel ceci oui madame ont des
enfants il vient me faire ça c'est nabab
à ça depuis que je travaille je vois ton
père une fois tous les six mois et à
chaque fois il est un peu plus furieux
qu à notre précédente entrevue m'a fait
entrer
heureusement vous êtes là tous les deux
comme ça vous allez m'aider à recevoir
la grèce bonjour si de plus en plus beau
ici évidemment tu vas bien ma petite
fille
moi oui papa mais toi tu l'as où tu ris
en rien du tout je ne suis ni triste ni
gai ni bien portants ni malade et cette
fois pas le moins du monde en colère
bonjour mon champ mon bon fromental
qu'est-ce qui a vu le jour un vieil ami
up vous savez lorsque la destinée
s'acharne sur un homme avec une certaine
insistance il tombe dans un état complet
des sensibilités de demandes mais qu'est
ce qui vous arrive
je suis révoltée non par exemple raconté
doubs sarah mais certainement cela vous
amuse et robin après 30
le service irréprochable on me flanque
la porte parce que le marine ma fille
exerce une profession scandaleuse
c'est comique enfin moi il me semble que
c'est comme attention je ne permet à
personne de dire que ma profession est
scandaleux même sceller un homme en
colère mais voyons gaz qu'on ne vous
fâchez pas c'est moi qui suis sur le
pavé mais par dans ses premiers mais
depuis quand et comment ça se passait
bien ce matin le directeur général doit
convoquer oui il m'a dit textuellement
depuis des mois monsieur je vous
prodigue des investissements vous n'en
tenez aucun compte en voilà c'est
l'école dé contribuer à prendre une
extension qui vous déshonorent les
escroquer de monsieur val qui ne sont
plus supportables dehors fromentel les
escrocs créé un voilà que les se fâche
encore alors je suis passé à la caisse
on m'a régler mon comté à dater de ce
jour je n'ai plus pour vivre que ma
retraite qui me semblerait dérisoire
c'est mon état d'esprit me permettait de
l'après si banal alors bon ça il faut
pas vous laisser abattre à simon vieux
vous est ce encore dans la force de
l'âge
je des relations et de l'amitié pour
vous moi je vais vous trouvez une
situation vous allez voir mais à ma
chère amie
il faut malheureusement que je fais dit
moi oui enfin remonter un peu tenez vous
devriez tâcher de lui trouver une petite
amie
ben oui mais il a tout de même 52 ans
bon j'en ai 55 à ouvriers mais vous
moi bien sûr moi et vous est riche mais
ça va oui
ira pas tu veux un café cette rencontre
a du cash fait non c'est inutile non non
mon père mais vous laissez pas abattre
comme ça vous êtes encore vaillant
lucide en pleine possession de toutes
vos facultés
vous voyez que je ne vous dis rien de
désagréable en effet vous m'avez
assassiné mais vous couvrez mon cadavre
2 mais ne vous entêtez donc pas dans
votre abattement et voyez les choses en
face enfin où il n'avait rien perdu de
vos connaissances techniques
je ne crois pas bon et bien alors
pourquoi toute cette science ce que vous
n'avez que trop longtemps employé à
ruiner vos concitoyens ne servirait-elle
pas désormais à les défendre
je ne comprends pas très bien c'est
pourtant clair je vous offre ici à
l'école des contribuables une situation
en rapport avec votre génie et les liens
qui nous unissent
qu'est ce qu'il a dit mais il arrive que
tout ce qu'il faut pour occuper une case
pour des routes
je bénis le ciel de me sentir
aujourd'hui incapable du moindre
mouvement violent car en réponse à votre
insulte aux propositions je vous aurais
probablement étranglée
je sais que tu sais c'est pas facile de
poser avec ton père reconnaît le médecin
le mef à défendre le contribuable - frau
montée
c'est comique on a fait ça au zoom ne
sont que c'est que yann en tant que
directeur des contributions est ce que
l'état vous donné par mois 90 millions
je vous en offre 200 mille deux cent
mille foyers c'est une somme qui vont
qu'on ait réfléchi ce que je fais si
régis venez on va on va barder
est ce que c'est ce monsieur demande si
monsieur peut le recevoir
ah bon et pourquoi est ce qu'il a mis sa
carte sous enveloppe cachetée à je ne
sais pas monsieur juliette sas et qui
nous lient papa moderne est chantoiseau
ministre des finances est alors pourquoi
alors enfin le ministre des finances est
chez moi et vous n'êtes pas super fan je
veux que la réflexion ce n'est pas tout
à fait simple c'est une peau nette et
n'apprend du tout aimé mais bien alors
il faudra savoir tout de suite mais pas
fait son entrée au baloutchistan olivier
biffaud mieux tu ne me rencontrent pas
le serai capable de me supprimer ma
pension de retraite qui n'a plus besoin
de sammier de prendre le travailleur
inea ce serait super mais pour me
déshonorer je ne trouve pas ça énorme le
prendre c'est le monsieur monsieur le
ministre
chemise je suis à la fois surpris et
flatté qu'est ce qui me vaut l'honneur
de votre visite
il ya de très importants jamais monsieur
je viens vous voir refuser d'un valet de
chambre
tiens oui c'est un garçon qui s'est
présenté chez moi hier matin et qui sort
de ces vous pouvez vous me surprenez
alors celui qui vient de vous introduire
chez moi et à mon service depuis 15 ans
à ce qu'au fond engagées tant de choses
en tête vous savez il s'agit peut-être
d'une cuisinière
ah oui alors là il ya quinze jours j'en
ai renvoyé
comment s'appelait tel attelage jamais
c'est celle là est une grosse brute
d'une petite rousse à 7,7 en huit mois
vous en étiez content non puisque je les
renvoyer oui oui mais j'ai tant de
choses à mon avis je le prends
volontiers mais ce qui m'étonne surtout
c'est que vous fassiez vous même le
recrutement de vaud domestique je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui j'étais aussi n'a
à la séance s'annonce et fastidieuse
l'enjeu comme ça voilà dites moi
pourquoi n'avez vous renvoyez qui savent
et dakhla et la cuisinière elle volait
trop bas
là on a beau ne pas être regardant il
faut quand même faire attention surtout
avec cette crise là à qui le dites-vous
aux parents en effet je me doute que je
devais être au courant mais en ce qui
vous concerne on n'a pas l'impression
qu'elle vous atteint beaucoup pendant la
crise vous êtes royalement installés au
rheu également c'est que vous avez tout
l'immeuble
c'est à dire que
les bureaux occupent les 4 premiers
étages et moi j'habite les les deux
derniers jeux presque aussi grand que le
ministère des finances en ordre vous
exagérez
en tout cas c'est mieux meublé ya plus
d'argent
d'abord je n'ignore pas que vous fait
d'excellentes affaires je n'ai pas un
plein tout ça sur notre dos d'un homme
saoul minimes dames est ce que vous ne
touchez pas 20 % de toutes les sols on
ne nous paie pas mais comment savez-vous
ça il n'y a pas un français qui ne
connaissent l'école des contribuables et
ses tarifs eux à côté vous me flattez
bruylant résulte que tout ce qui est
entré ici représente le cinquième de
tout ce qui n'est pas entré chez nous
mais vous savez il faut calculer très
bien vu c'est mon métier oui mais en ce
moment il n'est pas drôle je vous assure
j'avoue que j'aime être à ma place qu'à
la botte bien je vous comprends nous
sommes en train d'établir le budget il
se traduit par un déficit de 6 milliards
non mais je vous assure je sais c'est
pas comment je m'en sortir en bon vous
allez nouveautés des impôts nouveaux
la belle avance vous aurez encore pour
qu'on ne les paie pas avant ça je ferai
de mon mieux
nous allons voyons monsieur valtier
parlons sérieusement est-ce que ça va
continuer longtemps quoi monsieur le
ministre votre campagne anti fiscale
votre lutte contre l'êta vous
agissements insurrectionnel non monsieur
le ministre à un an et demi les impôts
directs entre est déjà mal mais enfin
nous tous sur tout même de 800 millions
à un milliard par mois pourrait vivre
depuis que les contribuables
quant à l'école et bien nos recettes
diminuent chaque loi est depuis que vous
avez des succursales dans toute la
france notre chute devient verticale
savez vous ce que nous avons acquiescé
le mois dernier non mais ça m'intéresse
de savoir 90,7 millions comment les
croque monsieur vous avez réduit les
ressources de l'état de 90 %
c'est un beau succès non pour moi je me
dis évidemment même si vous étiez
ministre des finances mais quadrillée un
autre langage
d'abord je ne suis pas venu ici on va
demander des causses mais c'est vrai ça
au fait pourquoi êtes vous venu ici pour
faire appel à votre coeur de français je
vous jure que depuis que vous défendez
le contribuable la république est en
danger
entendons-nous aulas vous me faites trop
d'honneur
je ne cherche pas à vous être à guerre
simplement un m'entendre avec vous si
possible vous ne me demandez quand même
pas de fermer l'école des contribuables
sur vous offrait une belle compensation
bac l le support me voulez vous être
député en ce moment non alors l'éditeur
pour ça va j'ai pas besoin de vous
dans n'importe quel arrondissement
j'affiche mon programme plus d'impôts je
pense au premier tour 1 s'est courue
et vous tiendriez parole monsieur le
ministre ne s'agit pas de tenir parole
il s'agit d'être élu voulez-vous que je
voulais me directeur général des
contributions vous n'êtes plus qualifiés
que quiconque pour occuper ce poste est
plus au moins avec vous nous soyons sûrs
d'équilibrer le budget c'est trop tard
monsieur le ministre avec la meilleure
volonté du monde je ne peux pas réparer
toutes les erreurs que la république
accumule depuis qu'elle existe
je ne peux qu essayer de faire en sorte
que ces victimes n'en souffrent pas trop
mais que diable les impôts au toujours
existé et oui mais je sais pas d'où vous
permettrait à l'eau oui oui c'est quoi
ça par exemple mais dont je ne savais
pas mais depuis quand un quart d'heure à
barbara comment voulez vous que je le
sais écouter ça sur ministre nommé il
commence à écouter sa cp lys on s'était
dit soyons rédacteur en chef de la
tribune et m'apprend que le ministère
vient de tomber
le sua lips euros aux bas merci mon
petit vieux ben oui tu as bien fait de
me prévenir
et bien vous allez vous le ministère est
tombée en mai au sénat
c'est la peine il est fou mais qui
forestier et poser la question de
confiance sur les grèves de saint
nazaire et quelle grève ils étaient 200
kg battu sur le travail on aurait pu
tomber comme ça au sénat c'est peter je
vous présente toutes mes condoléances
monsieur le ministre monsieur le député
sabah vous pouvez c'était pour un
terrible jusqu'à puis va me raconter
gaby devait l'emmener à genève la
semaine prochaine j'étais délégué à la
conférence internationale
la suisse et gertrude déteste ce pays
gertrude c'est ma femme vous avez retenu
deux chambres beaurivage vous êtes c'est
une occasion unique et inespéré elle se
faisait une joie de ma compagne est là
pour continuer bien vous emmènerai à
cannes mais ma femme vous l'ami bidasse
accompli tout ce système ne vous désolez
pas votre peut-être partie de la
prochaine combinaison c'est vrai on a
beau changer de ministère c'est toujours
les même manière qu'ils reviennent je
n'y tiens pas plus de ça ah non non en y
réfléchissant bien je n'y tiens pas plus
que ça non non c'est très ennuyeux tout
ce qui arrive mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez et vous ne pouviez même plus
aller dans votre dans votre maison à
neuilly vous la connaissez maison mais
si je ne pouvais même plus y mettre les
pieds mais si je cite une fois point il
était délicieux de 50 mille mètres en
bordure de seine mais mais non seulement
je la connais mais je l'admirais car je
la trouve superbe des dents qu'est-ce
qui doit falloir comme personnel là
dedans 1
ça va être extraordinaire non dites moi
monsieur le ministre
avec tous ces signes extérieurs de
richesse et de presse common à rédiger
votre déclaration de revenus
quand on dit la vérité c'est toujours
facile avant on sans indiscrétion qu'est
ce que vous payez d'impôts par an trois
cent cinquante mille pas plus là comment
mais mais mais je vais avoir beaucoup de
mal cette année je ne m'en sortirais pas
d'ailleurs je n'aurai plus le traitement
ministre une mes frais de représentation
gabino coûte pas cher gertrude aussi un
peu moins mental il ya les enfants dans
ce non je ne sais pas comment je vais
m'en sortir sans souci
oui vous ne seriez pas un moyen
c'est une demande lieu de donner autant
d'argent à l'état pour laisser aller
dites moi en quoi consistent vos revenus
de valeurs étrangères que je suis pas
toi vous et pourquoi allez je vous
demande s apprend donc leur rapport est
incontrôlable à peu près de bruit
seulement g12 domestique puis jardinier
quatre automobiles mais tout de même
assez difficile de déclarer 50 mille
francs
bah oui évidemment c'est ça aussi vous
étiez mon client mais n'ont rien mais je
me suis dit mais non ce propos sur la
poignée un quart d'heure vous étiez
encore ministre des finances je suis
tombé c'est juste
ah non je vous écoute et bien écoutez
c'est très simple vous savez que tout
français sans domicile et quelle que
soit sa fortune peut s'il le veut
échapper à l'impôt direct que demain
rothschild décident d'habiter l'hôtel
qui peut déclarer cent mille francs par
an vous ne me voyez pas à l'hôtel avec
ma femme et mes enfants at a délaissé
mois par les bons vous vendez votre
propriété de neuilly à votre valet de
chambre non ventes fictives
elle nous
vous coûtera que les droits de mutation
et il la transforme en hôtel de
voyageurs il appelle savant double
neuilly palace et et ils vont nous
toutes les chambres 10 francs par jour
et par personne suivait bien mon
raisonnement vaut domestiques deviennent
les employés de l'hôtel et vous un
client de passage plus de ses extérieurs
de richesse vous déclarez ce que vous
voulez non non vous pouvez vous me dit
oui alors c'est mon valet de chambre qui
paient la taxe mais pas du tout 10
francs par jour et par personne ni
sentir par son commerce est déficitaire
de plus que sa patente
vous êtes un homme prodigieux on incise
je commence à comprendre votre succès il
méritait hâtif qu'est ce que je vous
donne un nom sur le ministre non je trop
peureux que vous reconnaissiez enfin mes
efforts j'étais enchanté de faire votre
connaissance je vous enverrai des amis
et bien je ferai de mon mieux pour les
guider merci d'avancé pour me soigner ou
le plaisir de venir dîner chez moi même
ce soir mais quel jour êtes vous libre
et côté je vais demander à ma femme si
vous le permettez je serais ravi lui
être présentés elle doit dans son bureau
je vais lui demander quelles avancées
par juliette tu veux monter un second
chéri mais merci vous dites dans son
bureau
oui parce que madame valtier s'occupe
aussi de vos affaires oui avec quel
fièvre c'est à dire si je vous disais
que ma femme ne sait même pas faire une
addition
est ce que c'est pour ça que vous la
trompait c'est bien possible
je vous remercie de m'avoir trouver
d'excusé ou madame c'est moi qui
manifestaient le désir de vous connaît
monsieur chantoiseau et nous demandent
quel soir nous pouvons dîner chez lui
n'importe quelle soit passé monsieur le
ministre si nous sommes flattés oui je
ne suis plus ministre des piquants
depuis un quart d'heure ça fait rien on
est très content quand même
oui vous animez entendu à 20h30 aux
nuits penas on va chez monsieur marty et
je vois la compagne mais à quoi
pensez-vous monsieur chantoiseau un
petit air joyeux là tout d'un coup rose
je pense aux malheureux qui va me
succéder au final c'est qui se trouvera
devant un trou de 6 milliards doit être
à sa place
[Musique]
monsieur valtier mais pas là non mais il
va revenir tout de suite attendait le
mais pourquoi me fille et vous madame
j'ai tant de choses à vous dire
lesquelles
mais je voudrais vous parler je voudrais
vous parler de la fir leroyer elle fait
porter son dossier ce matin on ne peut
rien de l'examiner il faut que vous dire
son cas me paraît désespérée a mis la
lys est pas si les délais légaux voilà
des mois qu'il a reçues la sommation
avec frais le commandement il va être
saisi demain alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que nous fassions pour lui rien
pauvre leroyer ça fait de la peine pour
lui moi aussi
y'a vraiment des hommes sur lesquels le
sort s'acharne espère des mois quelques
fois des années au moment où ils croient
à toucher au but obtenir enfin le fruit
de leur patience de leur fidélité ont
fait juliette qu'est ce que je vous ai
fait après avoir donné tant d'espoirs
après vous être presque promise car
enfin nous avions pris rendez vous chez
moi à mercredi à 5h yacine one entière
vous attendu mais j'ai pas oublié je me
rappelle même que je suis pas venu
j'évite mois donnez moi encore deux mois
non non non non madame non ce jeu je
suis las d'attendre
et puisqu'il en est ainsi je n'hésite
pas à vous annoncer une nouvelle qu'il
me déplaît de vous voir à prendre par
les journaux de nouvelles
je suis fiancée j'épouse dans deux mois
une riche héritière
c'est pas vrai voici les preuves lui
faire part de mon mariage
videira montré non ce n'est plus la
peine
pourquoi parce que subit est un
prospectus de l'école des contribuables
parce que la riche héritière n'existe
pas mais à présent je suis sûr que vous
m'aimez et que ce rendez vous c'est
demain s'en faut que vous y viendrez
enfin à quelle heure la même alors à 5
heures vous vous rappelez l'adresse 32
avenue bijoux allons c'était d'écrire je
suis plus serein
[Musique]
aurais tu ne l'as pas du tout aller du
tu deviens un petit tour dans les
bureaux et gabès et superbe intérêts
elle ce mois ça donne à réfléchir
bonjour mon petit j'ai au grand jour
patron bon alors je t'enverrai toute
allure mon petit papa ou là dessus et
bien mais travailler c'est fou ce que
j'ai à peine mais comme de l'air joyeux
tout d'un coup c'est moi ce que j'aime
mon métier c'est
elle est charmante mais vous aussi vous
êtes devenu tout à fait je les garçons
et à toute la famille à l'avancé vous
transforme un homme vous êtes musique
chez moi je n'irai pas jusque là mais il
est vrai que la maison et est très
agréable très très accueillante
oui évidemment vous avez toutes les
raisons de vous y plaire à mon père je
réfléchis à quoi à mes propositions
1 allez faites plaisir à votre fille
venez chez nous comment fromentel ne
vous a pas dit voix dont il est révoqué
très drôle a alors naturellement je lui
ai proposé de venir travailler avec nous
quand on lui doit bien cette petite
compensation mais évidemment un tel
emploi lui réserverez bouge ça je sais
pas qu'est ce qu'on pourrait lui
attendait dont se bat et et bassoues
chef de la comptabilité pointe au point
tôt pour le coc a raison dans ce beau
jeu c'est sous les ors de ses
supporteurs qui lui même est sous les
miens vous avez parlé des appointements
oui 200 mille francs par an à 200 mille
fois et vous appelez ça une petite
compensation est énorme
il n'y a plus tout jeune cet homme là à
son âge
à bord tout un apprentissage à faire
sourire aux contribuables de le rabrouer
et puis tout à coup devenir poli commun
non moi je trouve ça à la fois hasardeux
et 3 rémunérés et qu'est ce que je mange
frais patron et je ne sais pas moi entre
80 et 100 me mais c'est ce que je
gagnais comme directeur des
contributions et peut-être par ces temps
de crise c'est déjà très jolie retrouver
comme ça du jour au lendemain
je sais ce dont je suis certain c'est
que cette situation est intolérable
les mecs elle se prolonge seulement
quelques secondes je vais sortir de mon
état d' insensibilité mais voyons bongo
du gabon l'a laissé seul avec bonjour
oui les offres de porter de sun sont
intéressants mais cent mille dollars par
ans c'est peut-être à étudier si on n'en
parlera plus tard et dont je vous trouve
bien dur avec fromentel moi je vous
trouve bien généreux enfin c'est tout de
même le père de juliette
c'est vrai j'avais oublié le le père de
juliette 1 c'est le père de j
donnez-lui tout ce que vous voudrez
enfin
il faut excuser un petit giro ça va être
un peu grisé ayed quoi mais
les six intelligent vous savez avec lui
je suis tranquille un je peux je peux
lui laisser la maison je peux partir me
remplace admirablement ont certes et un
point que vous n'imaginez pas vous même
est ce que ça veut dire ça ça veut dire
que vous allez être conclu
des doors & d est une idée fixe
vous ne pensez qu'à sa famille que c'est
ma fille qui pense voilà aujourd'hui
c'est giroud jeudi était sa maîtresse
est encore à vous savez bien que je vous
plais bien toujours attend ses joueurs
et je vous en remercie mais qu'est-ce
qui vous permettent de supposer
je ne sais pas un pressentiment et
l'impression tout à l'heure quand je
suis entré elle prenait rendez vous avec
lui pour demain à 5h 32 avenue bugeaud
32 avenue le jour j c'est l'adresse de
giroud c'est ce que j'ai compris
juliette mêmes antennes second set oui
battu le gars qui est un temps de 5 min
à leyment vite je ne me dites pas que
c'est moi qui non n'ayez pas peur
qu'elle existe vous voyez bon père à
quel point j'ai besoin de vous ici mais
je me rends compte et ce dernier
incident que dessine ma fille a besoin
d'une étroite surveillance alors je
foule aux pieds toutes mes convictions
et j'entre à l'école et contribuables
par dévouement patterns
par exemple vous aurez bien jusqu'à 250
une fois à condition qu'elle me restent
fidèles soit bon et bien voilà une
situation qui n'est pas de tout repos
on va vous êtes bien aimable d'une danse
tu veux le savoir je vais pas parler mes
enfants je vous laisse je vais me
présenter monsieur pointeau et le prier
de me désigner mon pupitre
je suis content alors qui dit non oui
mon enfant guerlain pout elle est
désormais ma devise sol
mon chéri qu'est ce qui attire si
pressés à me dire je dois te poser une
question julio tacheté coup tu apprends
crois qu'elle a fait la fête
juliette valtier quitta alors voyons la
chapelaude c'est parce que tu manques à
d'argent série ni c'est parce que tu
t'ennuies y est maintenant tu es riche
et tu es occupé alors giroux pourquoi
est ce si oui qu'est-ce que ça tu dis ça
veut dire que tu as un rendez vous
demain 5 heures avec lui et pas pour
parler des contribuables c'est inouï
alors voix d'or que tu sache déjà
je le sais depuis cinq minutes je te
prie de ne pas détourner la conversation
en gironde c'est autre chose que ce que
tu as encore me trouvais la non écoute
écoute castot je ne dirais pas un autre
que tout âge j rouge
je crois que tu es un peu amoureuse de
lui
une jeune femme résiste à toutes les
tentations mabille a résisté aux pas
parce que je ton père est là et qu'à
chaque fois il me revient à temps parce
que sympathique à prime abord heureux
mais enfin depuis que je suis au monde
je n'ai jamais appartenu qu'à toi
peut-être mais sans ton père de ma 5e
l'as tant aimée ton 1,6
aurais tu peux en dire autant oui bah
vivons au jour le jour venu il ya un
fait certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
peux encore te regarder entendu jusqu'à
ta prochaine incartade mais que demain
ton père soit en voyage mal à demander à
mon compte est bon mais je t'ai défendez
vos qualités cette place alex qu'un
souci en boîte on perd quand je sais que
la main va toi aussi
moi aussi je l'aimais non toi aussi je
t'aime petit exploit de ne rien
comprendre
tu m'aimes ah bah voilà autre chose et à
quelle heure place tu sais toi moi mon
attitude à tous ont prouvé que je
t'adore je ne me dis jamais que votre
sachet est des moments où je te le dis
quand on vient ont paru en ruine dans
ces moments là tu te diras irma alors
évidemment
comme en iran même année très sa
présence non mais non tu fais que ça ne
veut rien comprendre aujourd'hui je veux
dire qu'il ya des minutes où les mots
d'amour sont purement mécanique ça ne me
rend si une part alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
font ventes hors enseigne
je te parle d'amour du matin au soir et
oui ça signifie rien les gestes ce qui
compte c'est les mots pour être sûr que
tu m'aimes je voudrais lui pas être
forcés de réfléchir je voudrais n'avoir
qu'à écouter l'état dans lequel tu me
vois ne paraît pas concluants vie vexé
et non c'est toi qui es stupide ne pas
voir que je souffre je suis malheureux
que depuis notre mariage
je le pense strictement catoire bien dit
l'homme je te le dis il n'y a que ça
comment mieux que ça c'est pas beau avec
tendresse avec tous les noms de dieu je
suis en donne moi je peux pour être à
condition que tu ne peux donc pas il est
a dit le cheikh mais je crois que ça va
finir comme ça je comprends rien je suis
là
c'est la première fois que je dispute
comme ça et bien espérons que ce sera
pas la dernière
allons il ne me reste plus qu'à dire
agir ou que c'est encore remis
comment ont remis les lots non non non
non non j'emploierai cette expression
peut pas lui porter un trop grand coup
tu veux croire mais mais du moment que
tu m'aimes non il serait plus jamais
être question de huy écoute pour en être
tout à fait sûr je je vais lui en parler
moi même oui alors voulez vous montez
giroud s'il vous plaît merci
qu'est ce que tu vas lui dit tu vas
boire faut vraiment que j'aurais sont à
présent ce n'est pas inutile
est-ce qu'il ya justement j'ai vu ma
femme aime moins nous parlions de 2,2
de cette affaire de des états unis elle
les propositions de boxe stone me
paraissent intéressantes
haumea moi aussi oui et j'ai bien envie
de les accepter et bien vous ferez bien
vu voilà pour lancer une affaire
pareille on peut pas envoyer n'importe
qui à ça et j'ai pensé
oui oui vous avez pensé à quelque chose
que la sphère mérite que vous y alliez
vous même
tiens moi à votre place je partirai pour
new york pendant deux trois mois voit
installerait les bureaux je mettrai tout
ça en route
j'offrirai avocat la direction
permanente de la succursale il parle
l'anglais comme le français c'est
exactement le qu'il nous faut la mairie
mais s'est passé pas il ne s'est pas une
mauvaise idée du tout se mérite dans
pendant trois mois mais qui est ce qui
va me remplacer ici voyons madame
valtier mois
parce que ma femme resterai ici c'est
pas mal combiné moi j'ai eu une autre
idée
oui mon bon giroux je vous dois beaucoup
au 6,6 grâce à vous j'ai pu fonder
l'école des contribuables et c'est grâce
à vous aussi que la prise cet essor est
bien giroud montpetit giroud la sphère
de new york je vous en fais cadeau
comment seulement bien entendu c'est
vous qui partiraient uns et pas pour
trois mois
non parce que voyez-vous vauquelin ne
ferait pas le poids pour qu'une affaire
comme celle-là marche il faut que vous
la dirigez personnellement pendant
combien de temps
et bah écoutez après les trois premières
années et on verra à crier qu'en pensez
vous madame oui moi je pense que c'est
une bonne idée
mon mari vous fait là un cadeau que vous
méritez giro
et quand devrais-je par théo
immédiatement vous allez me convoquer
borchtchev tonnes pour ce soir on signe
séance tenante vous pouvez vous
embarquer demain vous avez un bon train
pour le havre ac 1 k il fait tout à fait
mon affaire
mais alors à vos ordres madame on en
aurait peut-être non non non non alors
ça te va comme ça c'est un mari d'élise
a mis du temps à percevoir m'excuser
vous diront oh lola mais j'ai même reçu
un tuyau et j'ai découvert le chômage
calme lorsque l'état perçoit deux
phrases sur la suffisance
il a quatre ans pour revenir se sont
aimés lorsqu'un contribuable s'est
trompé dans sa déclaration il n'a que
trois mois pour vérifier in situ notre
édito mais vous le saviez tous affaibli
mais je l'avais jamais fait attention
tandis que dans mon nouveau poste une
telle iniquité le meilleur de moi oui à
la ministre des finances que judy ma
façon de penser en bas il est parti et
puis d'ailleurs il est tombé
c'est dommage en face à vriller
j'attendrai l'otan rassurez vous
rassurez vous il y en aura toujours des
candidats nous chez lui samedi soir ça
ne dérange pas au contraire j'ai trouvé
charmant moi c'est vrai je trouve que ça
patine
attention au genre
non mais maintenant que vous travaillez
chez moi que vous serez toujours ici bon
père enfin je suis complètement 30 m
[Applaudissements]
nous avons eu la joie d'interpréter
devant vous et de messieurs louis
verneuil et georges hébert
les décors de roger à
[Applaudissements]
des costumes de donald cardwell
avec la distribution suivante il avait
levé mans
jean-pierre gernez
jean marsan
les linkers
ma dudicourt
green etc et relais
philippe dumas
[Applaudissements]
à la feydeau
daniel bol
et michel roux
et la mise en scène est de robert manuel
[Musique]